sixteen years old is a nice and
fiftyThree you opened up Newsweek
magazine and you saw your name what was
it like well it one of my first
publications a letter about Amelia
Earhart who I had been doing a research
project on for about three years at that
point it was just after the first Soviet
cosmonaut went up valentina Tereshkova
and I was indignant
that no American woman was eligible yet
for the space program as it happened
coincidentally that the first woman had
gone to space 35 years to the day since
the new year Hart had crossed the
Atlantic so I wrote into Newsweek and
they they published it now this was
before Betty Friedan's book was out
before feminism had its resurgence of
the 1960s so this is one of the one of
the documentary proof 40 years old now
in this year and that I'm a kind of or
feminist so one of the aboriginal
feminists of my generation of the 1960s
fast forward in 1972 you're traveling
and touring with your mother in
Washington DC you're watching on the
Senate floor and you see Barry Goldwater
for the first time in person what did
you think of it is a man of amazing
charisma he he had a kind of quality
almost what kind of I don't know what
was called a kind of a medieval warrior
of quality I think he touched me as an
intellectual somehow he radiated a kind
of mental force even from the straight
distance and the in the from the
visitors gallery
do you remember whether he ever had any
impact on you did he have it did the
fact that he was a Republican and where
you were moving in your political life
at that time well I had been campaigning
for John Kennedy 1916 I was I was 13
years old but I come from an area of
upstate New York was very conservative
Republican a lot of my family was I
would say on the conservative side on
the whole on the whole Republicans I
think is the family I came from you've
talked about the fact that you're very
unhappy with the labels of conservative
and liberal these days why I try I try
it seems just hopeless now but it for a
brief shining moment in the early 90s it
really seemed as if we were going to
move into
a new arena where there were less
inflexible polarizations about about
politics I feel that these designations
conservative and and liberal have long
outlived their usefulness but I'm afraid
that the the Monica Lewinsky affair
repolarized the nation and now at this
point with with so much disagreement
about the Iraq war and we're back to
some of the worst and most strident kind
of a discourse where they the nation's
divided down the middle in ways I think
what exactly is to heal it is it
possible though for us not to put labels
on people I would like more
sophisticated forms of labeling if
someone wants to call themselves a
rock-ribbed conservative Republican
that's fine but I myself am I am a
libertarian who disagrees with the
Democratic Party that I belong to on so
many levels I despised the current
direction of it of the Democratic Party
it's I could go on for hours about that
we voted for Bill Clinton I voted for
Bill Clinton twice and then became a
severe critic of the Clintons and then
voted for Ralph Nader for the Green
Party I'm looking hoping some Democrat
will come it should be an adequate
presidential candidate doesn't doesn't
look like we're going going to get
anyone to present moment at the same
time I find that the Democratic Party
has run out of ideas itself I mean it's
version of liberalism is nothing but tag
lines and and and the kinds of
diminution of of the Republican or
conservative position that I think is
reductive and and it's just causing an
endless inflammatory culture war in this
country
flashback 37 years here ten years old
and it says in some of the articles
about you that you kind of had you came
out you were a you were a very quiet
child which some people watching this
might be very surprised to hear a quiet
child oh yes I think I was fairly silent
I was very active I had a lot of
physical energy and as I was roaming
around wildly outdoors but I remember
once my mother was bringing me down to
New York City for a visit on the train
and she was complimented by other train
riders for the incredible good manners
that this little girl
wearing white gloves in I sort of
exploded my puberty guy exploded but
it's a classic story of a nineteen
sixties you know generational I belong
to we have some pictures here of you and
some of your Halloween costumes of youth
may be a little unusual at highly
unusual in the middle of the 1950's for
little girls to be disguising themselves
and as military officers in this case a
Roman soldier my my mother in life Ben's
father constructed that costume for me
they would have preferred that I have
chosen something else to be some other
sexual persona to be but I wasn't madly
in love with these images of heroic
masculinity at a time when you know
Doris Day and Debbie Reynolds were being
forced down on us the women now that's
me as the toreador s cameo from Carmen
that I'm probably six years old there
and again my mother and father
constructed that customer we had no
sword so that's my mother's umbrella
actually other than that we're living in
a small farming town of Oxford New York
at that moment where my father was
teaching high school but where did these
ideas come from how to do this I have no
idea to some something's missing in me
since a tiny child here I'm Hamlet there
that is at this point we're in Syracuse
like this is probably I'm eight or nine
years old at this point
I'd actually produced and directed a
rather shabby of the production of them
of Hamlet based on the classic comic
books in my fourth-grade class what is
good I didn't know no Hamlet I'm afraid
kept forgetting his lines and this kind
of a fiasco and what are you where are
you here was fast-forwarding a little
bit um I'm going to see this photo
okay oh I didn't see that now that's
that I'm in the classroom at my first
job at Bennington College since 1973 I
have my Keith Richards shag haircut
keepers an enormous idol of mine for
myself I'm wearing a my Edward Ian cut
green corduroy jacket my trademark in
that era when did you first decide that
you were unhappy with the way that
people express themselves through their
gender in the 1950s it was a time of
great repression in terms of sex roles
it was a very definite way that a girl
was supposed to be I think that's
my father encouraged me to to aspire to
whatever I want to do to do he taught me
how to defend myself with my fists it's
necessary my father did not raise me
indeed they I think the conventional way
you'd expect an italian-american
immigrant family as mine was but there
was some something in me we just wanted
to achieve what did you achieve for
women I was constantly indignant about
the the role sentiment subordinate role
differential role that was assigned to
women especially the need to be polite I
like the way men could speak out men
could be challenging but women were
expected to to have soft feminine voices
that kind of a thing so it was just a
constant clash with the with gender
roles throughout the 1950s remains
that's why I identified very strongly
with the transgendered today I take
absolutely understand with what they
went through on the other hand I never
had any desire to change sexes I
expressed my my problems with
socialization through achievement
through through writing I think my books
on in some way my own form of sex change
well that's what we're here all about to
talk about and that is to talk about
your books what is it about you have you
have said that the picture is very
important for you in terms of explaining
your views to people but what is it
about the written word is that more
important less important than the
picture and what's your thought on that
I feel I'm in love with the English
language which is new to my family it
has to be remembered my mother was born
in Italy and all four of my grandparents
so English is new and my parents made
the decision to have English spoken only
in the home and that's why I posed by
language education I believe the
immersion in English English which is a
very difficult language so I've been in
love with English I've heard for example
Lewis Carroll's Elson want Alice books
I'm not hearing those voices those
British forces actually and being
fascinated by mysterious almost kind of
imperious statements coming out of it
out of the characters of Alice's world
and wondering what they meant and
and wanting to speak like that so I feel
like been studying English as if from
the outside my entire life have always
taking notes always taking out something
I was always looking upwards always
assembling materials I have to do with
English now I'm also in love with with
the image and that I knew from the
Italian Catholic Church they seemed
anthony's anthony of padua church in
Endicott New York which was all the
stained-glass windows and the the
statues of Saint Michael and and Saint
Lucie that's the iconic form of almost
choreographic expression of the saints
of the Catholic Church with their
weapons or their or their emblems say
Lucy you're holding out a plate with
eyeballs on it I found that very very
odd very interesting so my whole
interest in Hollywood actually and and
in in dancers and in actors is coming
from what I perceived sv is a ritualism
and the gorgeous like in ography of the
Catholic Church so my career I've tried
to blend these two things my love of
language with my love of the image who
taught you how to write I don't think
anyone taught me how to write I just I
think I taught myself hard hard to write
by whatever I would find a passage that
struck me as unusually eloquent or
interesting I would copy it out now the
adage is that muscular copying copying I
did that for years ever since I've been
in private junior high school copying
out passes given notebooks of passages
in the embeds just that copying through
and trying to understand the way the
sentence works so to all the different
voices in English actual are in my
writing I don't have one voice people
think that you know I have I don't have
a recognizable voice who I'm speaking
but not when I'm writing there are
probably a hundred different voices that
I that I have that were imitating or
combining in a kind of improvisational
manner of the the right I particularly
admired over over the years so what was
the impetus for this first book 1990
hardback 1991 paperback as yes so
persona is an expansion of my dove my
doctoral dissertation at Yale I got my
degree in 1974 and the probably it was
Simone de Beauvoir the second sex with
a Belgian colleague of my father's had
given me in 1963 and that is when I
transferred my interest in it before
that I'd want to be an archaeologist or
I was thinking of going into literary
service but this idea of of of producing
a mammoth book a book at something that
could be a monument for in terms of
women's achievement I thought that women
did not aim high enough I wanted it
something massive you know for women in
Bible I want to say that something
crushing crushing okay on a kind of
grand scale I feel that men have for too
long in history been the ones to make
the epic statements or in in rock and
roll and always complaining why is it
Led Zeppelin George evil geniuses who
had a giant orchestral sound why is it
that women will not make big obnoxious
you know they're like sort of almost
like a military tank way of crushing the
audience that's what I want to do to
producing massive book and that's only
half of the book I actually wrote sexual
song it was a second volume that was on
popular culture with thousands of pages
long this manuscript and I'm very
grateful to nail press for having taken
a chance on it when seven other
publishers had had rejected it and if
that when Harold Bloom came into your
life well Harold Bloom was my
dissertation director in in graduate
school he I had not studied with him at
BO graduate school but he heard through
the student grapevine what I was
intending to work on which is this area
of sexual ambiguity and moral ambiguity
in in the whole history of the
humanities he summoned me in his office
he said to me my dear I am the only one
who can direct that dissertation okay I
said oh okay and there began one of the
greats seems to me in a collaborations
like I Oh Harold Bloom so much just for
believing in my ideas understanding
everything I wanted to do and and being
my support for all those years when no
one understood I there are a few a
couple of my friends I think I
understood what I was going to do but no
one else did and I introduced that book
in the face of massive rejection of
everything I ever wrote in terms of the
pieces of the book it just took a level
of persistence or mania I don't know I
think few women have March 1991 what was
the impact of this cover story on the
New York well my books
superstone had been out a year earlier
without my picture on it with no
publicity no one knew who I was I was
completely unknown working at an obscure
art school in Philadelphia the
University of the Arts and in the
Francesca stanphill who is a very
sophisticated woman a writer and
journalist in New York was interested in
sexual persona for for its defensive art
she felt that as I did that too much of
feminism and an academic style was was
of suppressing the you know the the
aesthetic qualities in art so she was
she was attracted to my book and then
something out and it ended up as this
cover story where people saw me for the
first time and on that cover I am posing
with my Keith Richards face that's the
one that that's in the armor room of the
Philadelphia Museum of Art people see
right here there's army redneck which is
my military my halloween costume
background and she is there so that so
there I was and I was taking positions
at the time were highly controversial
highly controversial in feminism but now
apparently all of my ideas have a part
of a cultural landscape thanks to a
younger generation of women that came
through who agreed with me I was taking
a pro sex Pro pop Pro rock position
about about feminism I was saying women
are not victims all kinds of things now
that people are just accept but at the
time it created a storm of controversy
what were you saying about Gloria
Steinem at this game well Caloris time I
admired Gloria Steinem when she first
came on the scene I thought that she was
a very good a very telegenic face for
feminism but I shouldn't be dragged into
the movement by Betty Ford and for
heaven sakes I was out there doing my
Amelia Earhart crazy things in the early
64 asanam was running around New York in
a plastic dress or doing a book called
the beach book at that period so I don't
know anything
- Gloria Steinem I'm saying that
feminism as a cohered is ideology in
1970s turned against sex turned against
men became absolute Laura Steinem said a
woman needs a man like a fish needs a
bicycle all right now it's at the same
time as she was never seen without a man
in parties in New York I found a site I
thought it was a Paul
to indoctrinate young women to inoculate
young women with an anti male bias I
come out of an Italian culture where a
strong man and strong women the men
Italian men were fabulous the men could
do everything of every generation right
from my grandfather's generation my
uncles and my father's generation do
anything with their hands I say they
were men of Honor
okay men of ethics if it has men being
impugned as racist and oppressor as
amended and an imperial listened and
brutalized and rapists and everything
else seemed to me a terrible way to
educate women and what was the backlash
like when you were saying this stuff
publicly in front of the feminine well
in the early 90s it was at people who
saw who people were there will remember
for example at Brown University in 1992
700 people turned out I mean probably
half of them wanted to know who I was
and it was screaming and the yelling
that went on now the reason up to this
point okay up to this point such crowds
to harass the speaker they had worked I
had worked on people it didn't work with
me because yeah because I am a performer
okay III do improv I do improv so I was
not there reading some prepared text
that they could disrupt okay they would
throw things from the audience right and
I would go right back s and I use stings
that drawn from films I had seen all
kinds of things
I kept the audience laughing and in fact
it was it was probably the most famous
one is when I gave a lecture at MIT in
in 1991 and the Boston police said it
had to be called our thousands of people
turned out people who are tired of the
political correctness of the 1980s and
wanted something new because what I
stand for I stand for it
anti Dogma anti ideology the free mind
and a free voice that's why I stand for
I am NOT I am not a part of any group I
don't belong to you know any any circle
who's whose ideology I'm trying to uh
trying to put forward you have said that
probably the most notorious sentence
that you have ever written is this one
it's civilization had been left in
female hands we would still be living in
grass huts mm-hmm slap in the face to
women no what I'm saying is that oh that
women have been close to nature have had
a kind of ecological view of nature
perhaps from the very beginning and that
it that we would still be living in
and grass huts meaning we will be in in
dwellings made of perishable materials
organized around a hearth
okay see because I regret sentimental
Omaha that that the whole impulse toward
building in stone toward breaking
through the the barriers the boundary
lines of the tribe of the extended
family actually is coming from men men
like force themselves out there and die
or even slaughter I think it's men who
who have called you know the great
migrations in human history that
expanded the range of the species and
they're the ones who are always building
the great bridges and building the great
monuments risk-taking terrible physical
risks but I think that throughout
history you've had this you know the
kind of magnetic symbolism of the horse
that is associated with with women and I
think it seems quite natural women when
they're pregnant or when they're nursing
babies need to be still you can have
love identified with the Amazon the
Amazons you know with their bows and
arrows who ran with the men who went out
with out with the hunting expeditions
and brought back the meat and did all
the dirty work 1990 again this would
have been the year that the sexual
persona came out in hardback you were
writing in the New York Times
uh yeah Madonna yes yes and you wrote
that she was the future of feminism the
first op-ed piece I wrote was this
defense of Madonna and not in at the end
of 1990 that was what the first thing
that where people realized also kind of
who I was and at the end of that article
I said Madonna is the future of feminism
now this was in nineteen nineteen ninety
people said this is completely mad
people effeminate wrote in it this is
completely this was terrible this is
awful sheep she prostitutes the image of
women etcetera it turns out to be
accurate because a whole younger
generation of women came forward
influenced by Madonna who embraced their
sexuality embraced fashion and beauty
and and throughout all that anti-male
you know anti-pornography kinds of
obsession of the 1980s of feminism of
android Dworkin and Catherine MacKinnon
so now when I was saying in the early
1990s that Charlie's Angels had been
to me part of the cutting edge of
feminism moving forward people thought I
was mad or the Bond girls I love the
James Bond girls whoo-hoo-hoo feminism
Norma thought of as sexist well here we
are
you know after over a decade later and
Charlie's Angels is an remakes you know
to them to movies The Drew Barrymore has
put out you know with with them the Bond
girls have documentaries about them on
you know on cable TV so I feel as if I
just felt like a paradise all of the
issues that people were trying to lynch
me for in the early 1990s all those
arguments are over and the younger women
have won have they also won in that
issue where you wrote a news day in 1991
about date rape you said the date rape
controversy shows feminism hitting the
wall of its own broken promise right now
that might my essay for it women say
early 1991 is probably one of my most
reproduced pieces of writing and yet
have it in I should say in sex art in
American culture which was your book
from 1992 yes - a collection now that is
today it's in it's in college readers
with in composition texts it's it and
the reason for that is that teachers
have found that it stimulates discussion
among the students what I'm saying in
that article is that women must take
responsibility if they are emancipated
for their own behavior in social
relationships that we have to give
beyond the period of the chaperone the
dueña of the avenging male figures the
you know the brother who will come in
and punch out your date for you I found
that the that the feminism of the 80s
early 90s was asking male authority
figures back into sex at what that just
was running to the authority figure come
and punish him for what he did on the
day I stopped that a strong woman should
be prepared to negotiate her own social
relationship and be ready to defend
herself and I said for example about
Madonna did you know I said you know if
you even address like Madonna you have
every right to dress like Madonna but if
you're going to just like Madonna at 3m
okay if you're advertising you better be
ready to sell this is the point I'm
making that the way you dress in the way
you behave is actually what you actually
there are these subliminal messages that
are below the level of yes or no in
sexual relationships I'm saying to women
do not put yourself into positions from
which you have to be rescue again free
women must be ready to defend themselves
at the time was a radical view but now
again I think that it's seen as a
sensible view and do you feel that today
are you ready to when you go out to to
support yourself to defend yourself even
physically well I feel that no one has
the right to put his or her hand on you
without your permission okay that you
are the total rule of your own body if
you say no at any stage and in sex is
actually that the person must stop
nevertheless there are very crazy people
out there there are people who are just
mentally disturbed I always say you know
like Ted Bundy that the rate murderer
gay was extremely charming man that's
the problem today with all this sort of
strange you're dating women should not
be putting themselves under the control
of strangers it's a women you have to be
you have to be aware that with freedom
with modern masturbation come
responsibilities
Camille poly has decided to be with us
for three hours this afternoon we thank
her for that and we're going to open up
our phone lines and invite you to join
us here's how you can join in 202 585
three eight nine zero if you live in the
East or Central time zone 202 5 8 5 3 8
9 1 if you live in the mountain or
Pacific time zone you can also email a
question if you would prefer to do it
that way and the address is book TV at
c-span org again that's book TV at
c-span org and some people have already
emailed in questions I'm just going to
dig into them this first one by Anne
Marie McMahon
from Catholic University she's a major
in music history and literature asks
what your take is on Ann Coulter and
culturally sizing and culture is a I
said I think she has a brilliant mind I
I'd love to watch her trash
all those genteel ladies on the network
TV when she goes on she's uncontainable
on the other hand I do feel that she
should take more time with her written
materials I think that there's an
inflammatory and perhaps I'm afraid
sometimes careless way that the books
have been assembled that have allowed
her opponents to criticize her and
dismiss her work so I I wish that she
actually I wish that she were a college
teacher I mean I wish that she were more
part of the institutional setting
this email question asked you what do
you think do you think that Hillary
Clinton will ever be President I don't
about I hope that Hillary will will run
my history with Hillary is a long one I
was sitting on the hill don't even show
1992 debating Susan Faludi on the very
day that Hillary on the campaign trail
made her infamous remark well I could
have stayed home and Jays cookies on
Amazon so Dunn who ran this tape for us
it was the only thing that Susan Faludi
I agree that we both admired Hillary
very much we thought this is fabulous so
a woman of the nineteen-sixties
generation and you know I voted for the
Clintons and I became so disillusioned
with with the Clintons and wrote a
notorious cover story for the New
Republic in 1996 called
Ice Queen drag queen they create an
enormous storm and then slowly I think
many liberals came to my view became
more suspicious of Hillary but I had a
turnaround when I reviewed her her new
book for The Times in London recently
and I felt that it was a credible
statement of the continuity of her
thinking about about social policy from
long before she met Bill Clinton I felt
that even if she you know I could I
could hear her voice and even if others
helped her with the book I thought this
is a woman who knows how to hire a good
staff because that is a
well-put-together book now that book is
selling and selling and a book like that
doesn't just sell for PR it's selling
through word-of-mouth because people are
enjoying the book and the picture so she
needs to run but I would prefer a Dianne
Feinstein okay who is really I'd its
mired in science and she's mature she's
articulate she's steady she is deeply
informed in intelligence issues about
you know security issues and so on I do
wish she were running for president now
you did say in a Newsday quote it may be
more about Bill Clinton than Hillary
Clinton anyone who stays married to an
infantile drooling cereal groper
deserves what she gets
and by that I mean I don't care about
their marriage I really don't care
whether Hillary stays married to Bill or
not that's irrelevant to me I I believe
in private behavior in the private realm
but then the public realm is where women
needs to achieve I don't care what goes
on I don't care if the crockery is
flying lamps that's lying I don't care
ok I I just concerned about Hillary's
behavior in the public on here I have to
say I want
her to not be so insulated by by the
security guards and and then a PR she's
like always rolling like Ivy Tapper own
and it's this kind of a cocoon and she
doesn't really deal get engaged with the
people I think that's what she's missing
that's why I just fail to see how she's
going to win many primaries aside from
the north east and the west coast she
doesn't have the experience of just
going out and in a grueling way on the
campaign trail
and mingling with people in an
improvisational manner well you don't
have a security guard but how do you
guard your own privacy
I am extremely private person and people
may see me on TV okay but I absolutely
value my privacy of above all I'm not
out I don't shoes I'm not out it's you
know it's a fancy events of movie
premiere is always doing invited all
kinds of things I just I don't know that
I just I try to feel I'm a thinker and a
writer and a teacher and I need to
preserve in my inner rhythms I provide
you know I live in the suburbs like work
downtown Philadelphia but I live in the
suburbs I must have trees you know I
feel like an ordinary person I go to the
shopping mall I want to I want to
preserve that sense of ordinariness and
always be responding to life as it
occurs okay many of our writers have
allowed us in to show our viewers where
they write as a way of explaining to
them you said no really no because of
your privacy and you also didn't want
our cameras or any cameras and where you
teach exactly ever since from the moment
I became known in the media in the early
1990s I that was that was absolute line
I drew I will not let reporters into the
classroom I think it's wrong to allow
your students to be made somehow props
of your off-campus prominence I think
that's completely on how we're getting a
very large lecture that's different and
then people with a large audience I'll
be quite different but no I've never
permitted that I think that it's very
important to have a ton of privacy oh my
god is it where I work at myself you
know how I work my desk Oh My heavens
that's like what for my soul but you
have you have a website of your fan your
fans have a website free well they may
have created it but I certainly don't
their number of them have been created
over the years in the web is just a mass
of
misinformation of other things people
have-have created sites but I do not
have my own website they say that's
electronically stalking you do you feel
that way
electronic slow electronic stocking not
at all because because I was such a part
of when I joined salon magazine I was
writing for it from its inaugural issue
on right up until 1990 1995 to 2001 when
I left to join the activity of now at
Interview magazine but you know I feel I
was part of some of the construction of
a voice on the web for nonfiction for
magazine articles and and so on so I
feel I feel part of you know part of a
pioneering quality of the web of the
1990s let's get to some phone calls for
you Louisville Kentucky is first
yes dr. peckler I'm a huge fan of yours
and I certainly hope that you continue
your would restart your column every
once in a while thanks I've been a great
fan of yours but what I'd like to ask
you is the first time I heard of you was
like a kind of an intellectual explosion
went off and and and someone actually
talked about sexual liberation and but
not being part of the V as you call it
the a lot V of radical left or something
and I'd like to know as a conservative
myself and someone whose sexual
liberation how do we convince these
people to be to understand that the two
are possibly compatible conservatism and
sexual liberation well I have detailed
my philosophy in a long piece called no
law in the arena in my book dancing
trance and there I feel that there
should be a strict line between the
private realm and the public I feel that
in the private realm that that the
government has no right to intrude where
people conduct themselves with other
individuals as long as consensual and
behavior I feel that the government has
no business in crossing that line but in
the foot of the public realm I think
that is the area where we can ask for
standards and for example you know Bill
Clinton that could have been could have
had a thousand mistresses in a million
motels in this world I would have
applauded him but to use the the
hallways off
the Oval Office was a disgrace that's
the public realm okay that should not be
violated by private peccadilloes bands
of tramps 1994 this is what it looked
like
do you remember what it was like there
posting for discovered well I designed
that cover okay I'm using and I'm
imitating okay a number of things diana
rigg in the avengers at that point
that's what came to mind when i got i'm
also entertaining i am a favorite war
Andy Warhol picture of Elvis Presley
about to draw from a holster I mean I
actually have a knife strapped to my hip
and I have a and are a jacket a military
jacket from the army-navy store surplus
jacket and I'm wearing and I'm this is
what I'm saying is will again the
freewoman must be ready to make her own
way in the world that's what excites I
could additionally armed Amazon San
Francisco yeah
Camino I want to thank you for the
further work you're doing and for the
image of hem anism that you're putting
out where women can be strong and can
can partner with men that is being
against me okay the question I wanted to
ask you is to could you talk about
broadly what what you think about sex
work as you know prostitutes have been
them both dignitize by the mainstream
culture and oppressed they legalized and
also have been made them made villains
and victims by the by de semanas some
feminists well in my writing I've taken
a strong position of defense of of
prostitutes of strippers of drag queens
in fact add the title of my book vamps
and tramps is an allusion to this aspect
I feel that you see that that Western
culture is actually a fusion of two
traditions the judeo-christian which is
I'm afraid often rather anti sex and in
many of its incarnations and the a
greco-roman going all the way back
actually to ancient Babylon so what's it
what the Bible condemned as Babylonian
sexuality I have celebrated in my in my
own work I don't think that you know
that prostitutes should be should be
soliciting in the doorways of schools or
churches or things like that I think
there's room for for questions of public
order
but again
I you know I am proud to say that I
support support prostitutes and have a
feeling of solidarity with them so
Daniel Lewis from Washington DC asked
this in an email question sex and
sexuality has always had a role in
American politics how is your role how
is your view is how in your view is our
time different from others
I guess bringing this the sexuality
issue back to politics well we had this
enormous explosion of the sexual
revolution in the 1960s and and in the
the entire decade just when madly out of
control so that we that there was a
conservative reaction by the end of the
end of a decade in Richard Nixon some
election so then what happened is that
you would think that the that the
progressive or liberal side of sexual
equation feminists and so on would would
take up the flag instead there was an
odd kind of a fusion between a
doctrinaire feminism of Andrea Dworkin
and Catherine MacKinnon with with
conservatives to drive for example
Playboy and penthouse out of the
convenience stores and Dworkin and to
her people want which tried to pass laws
that were later declared local
ordinances that were later declared
unconstitutional there was all kinds of
statements and pornography causes rape
things like that which I think if
absolutely never been proven so again
we've been getting a strange eruption of
our Aboriginal Puritanism again and
again even though the country itself is
geographically so much larger the New
England Puritan tradition seems to
return again and again and it so that
our arguments about sex
particularly sex as a pleasure politics
seem rather naive an idealistic to
Europeans who don't care at all what
politicians do in their in their private
hours so I think that the Puritan
influence is also though it's positive
in terms of our the way we work hard in
America this isn't some rigor
self-discipline of of Independence and
free thought that also was with the
Puritan influence I'm afraid it's built
into our character I don't see how we're
ever going to escape it is that whole
issue of gay marriage which is come up
most recently
plans I'm on the record on this question
of gay marriage since the early 1990s
and I speak about also and no longer
invention cramps and I feel that that
that it's a mistake ever to use the word
marriage for the marriage is a word
associated with the sacraments of the
church going back to to Latin the word
marriage a sense from the Latin Rite why
gay activists have have inflamed
situation further with this about using
that word I prefer the idea of a
domestic partnership or civil unions I
feel that that what needs to be
investigated is any special benefit
given to heterosexual married couples
that is not being would not be given to
two unmarried heterosexual couples or
who are life partners and also a
homosexual partner I think that's what
we need we need the state and and church
must be separated and wherever wherever
we have any kind of intrusion of
religion some assumptions in government
process I believe they have to be
removed and that that is in fact a
thrust of the last 250 years of the
development of the modern democracies is
that have that played out in your own
life - I guess the question is in your
own life if you had time to in your own
relationship in which you felt like well
I've been with the alpha Maddox for ten
years now and we've discussed I think
you know if what we abridged as domestic
partner you have a with my I'm lucky
enough in my University you know offers
that there aren't that many benefits
that accrue to it but I do think there
are things I mean this is about oh
you're at the living wills or being
excluded from from the room at the
hospital or property whatever that's
it's absurd protests that any gays are
making because you can you can make your
own will and makes you make sure that
all these things are taken care of
however in cases of Social Security
let's say what Social Security does not
transfer to a homosexual partner that
really needs to be looked at in terms of
in terms of passed a precedent it may I
take this opportunity may identity to
say that a scoop for c-span our family
expanded last year Allison gave birth to
a son
Ellucian I have kept it completely out
of the media very successfully he'll be
a year old this fall and scoop what's
he's been what has that done well um
it's been great just incredible I mean
it's been quite quite amazing
going amazing how do you plan on
bringing him up well I hope as a
freethinker Alison is a free thinker
isn't real I am and she's a an artist
and independent arts curator very
productive year last year she produced a
book called a Sex in the City an
illustrated history of sex in New York
and I wrote the introduction to that
called American Babylon where I show all
the very eerie kind of resemblances
between between Manhattan and the
Babylon of antiquity that now has to
come back into the news so much because
of our incursion to Iraq let's go to
Bowie Maryland I guess first average
respect miss put on this speaker there
and I had two quick ones first on
feminism I think there's a split between
what I would say were to reform and the
revolution reform was just you know get
rid of the bad degrading treatment and
the abuse but they basically accept
secondary treatment you know the
chivalrous type thing and then there's
the revolution who really want truly
quality and to me Sally I think there's
not very many women who really want to
be equal and I went you're throwing that
but my main point is about liberal I
consider myself a liberal and I'm able
to criticize anyone and and really bring
new thought and I want to know do you
have a problem with the definition
because most people that are referred to
as Liberal Democrats they're really
leftist who are conservative meaning
that they have an agenda just to say a
Tom DeLay is a religious person and he
takes his worldview and tries to fit the
facts to that there's plenty leftist who
take their worldview and try to fit the
facts whereas to me a liberal is someone
who looks at all the facts and is
informed by as many responsible sources
as possible it didn't try to do what's
best for as many people as possible and
to me that's what a liberal is as
opposed to a conservative who says well
what does the Bible say well that's my
view and and I just wondering can there
be a better is there a group for what
I'm talking about or is it am i destined
to be called a liberal even though I
don't support the teachers union I don't
you know people say you support the
teachers union you know there's a list
that they call liberal when they're
really just left you know there on the
left
wait thank you yeah those are so much so
much in there and so much yeah I mean I
think in many ways of the
liberal wing of the Democratic Party has
become a hostage to special interest
groups and the teachers union everything
else that's what that is that is a
serious problem but I think in general
one can one can say that the
conservative is someone who looks
backward to a time when things were
better when when a time of the forebears
when where there were bedrock
traditional values that we need to
return to where as a liberal is
generally looking forward in thinking
how to remake society to to so to be the
liberal freedom rules to the
Constitution as more malleable as a
document that is in evolution that needs
to be constantly revised from from
century to century whereas the
conservative will say this is what the
founders envisioned and we must not in
day in their wisdom that they must not
be deviated from but right now I think
all these terms are kind of a terrible
model when I came on the scene in the
early 90s it was it was a PC era the
political correctness I had was
entrenched in the major media were
utterly hostage to it the lis there was
a kind of doctrinaire liberalism that
was quite automatic at that period and
also in the university campuses and then
over the period of the 90s and it's
almost reversed so at the beginning of
the 90s I think in conservatives younger
conservatives in particular had a
tremendous intellectual kinds of
alertness because they were attacking
all these old dinosaur like precepts of
liberalism that had were now had no
connection to contemporary life but now
it's also what kind of reverse I think
that the word liberal is starting to
come back again and to perhaps be
rejuvenated and for just what the caller
said to bring it back this old idea of
someone who is what it was open-minded
future-looking right but I don't want to
do to abandon either one I think we have
to build on the great things in the past
for always with a sense that you know
that that's that the society is a human
creation it is an organism itself and it
should constantly be revised and not
allowed to ossify or to calcify Crescent
City California
hello mrs. Hagley oh I I really want to
express my admiration for your
intellectual integrity and you read here
to rigorous academic scholarship
scholarship thinking of this is so so
refreshing and so rare to have a degree
that you have in my opinion thank you I
would like to ask your opinion about two
things about the professor Allen Bloom's
book in the 80s as they called the
closing of the American mind whether you
think it was accurate and it is very
helpful and is still pertinent and also
what do you think of the International
Association of scholars a group of
professional professors are organized to
try to fight the political correctness
of correctness thank you so much for
your efforts I thank you appreciate it a
lot thank you
oh well well that Alan blooms book is
usually thought to have inaugurated the
culture war it's an attack on the
academy and under the provincialism of
American thinking and so on I I agree
with Allan bloom but about the need for
for these selection of great works that
students should be educated about I
believe there is a continuity in Western
culture that is too too much today on
campuses it sort of thrown off the
window but but there is a kind of a
coldness or a kind of limitation to
Allan blooms view of what culture
consists of I myself am much more
interested in movies and and and the
media and also the visual arts and I
feel that album is a philosopher and
therefore there is there's a kind of
rationalism perhaps in his point of view
that I felt as a member of that in
sixth-generation is a little bit
constraining because we are the rock and
roll generation that about emotional
expression that's why I felt was neat
and a khadeem a khadeem has gotten very
desiccated by the time by my mentor
Harold Bloom was having his clashes with
it as well in the late 50s and 1960s so
I think elm Blume deserves credit he was
an honorable man who I think did an
enormous service by putting this thing
on the center stage for us to discuss
but at the same time I would supplement
his his work or his his educational
model by about 59
a lot of things right then the second
thing National Association Scotland
thank you the National Association of
scholars I wish they would they're doing
good work but I did not as prominent yet
I don't think they're quite as people
today's savvy as I wish they were I
myself do not belong to that group I
also was disillusioned with the MLA the
Modern Language Association and I quit
it in disgust okay to join the new and
dissident media ecology Association that
was founded by Professor Lance Strait
str8 EE of Fordham University and the
the great models of this organization
are Marshall McLuhan a great hero of
mine from the 1960s and neil postman of
NYU who is a severe critic of
contemporary media and media ecology is
an analysis of the entire environment
that we exist in it's built books and
technology and and radio television all
those things that change us that become
us and we know what's in the the whole
point of this association is to find it
is the two basis of our Toronto in New
York City a North American vision of the
media that we created
enough with the Frankfurt School from
Germany the antediluvian thing enough
with Lacan very damn Foucault the French
who know nothing about Bowdre there are
nothing about American culture these
people okay no these are the idols on
campus so people who are interested in
joining the Association please look at
the website media ecology Association we
have this website and five years old now
and booming Chattanooga yeah thank you I
was wondering if you have any comments
on the concept of the shadow I did not
say it much in your works when I read it
and also why do you think television
hasn't been a more effective tool in the
classroom thank you
the shadow shadow you are you referring
to the the radio Sheldon is that what
you're preferring to color I'm not sure
caller you still there anyway I hiring I
haven't written anything about the
shadow but a television in the classroom
I am II I'm a little bit skeptical about
television in the classroom I think that
students already have too much
television outside the classroom they're
raised with it now I I love television I
have five
my husband and his [ __ ] I can go
through the whole house and not miss
anything
but I feel the quality of television is
declining enormous ly I think that what
students need is much more training in
the old fundamentals of how to how to
read and write I think that that the
students are graduating from from school
these days with a gluon pablum
it's the graduates of the Ivy League
heaven sakes are like drifting into into
jobs in New York City and they can make
it you know they can't they their
general knowledge cultural knowledge it
seems to me so limited they didn't have
basic skills
I think they you know even spelling I
mean things that they have to do with
lunch the kids know how to work the
computer they're masters of the computer
but what I'm worried about is a decline
in book writing and art making if when
University University of the Arts has
that I've been teaching 20 years next
next year and has every kind of the
traditional fine arts major in it from
illustrations of ceramics to into new
things like writing for film and TV it's
jazz dance and acting all kinds of
things on and they also have a web
design in web work and people my
students who are in this area are so
forward-looking with the people are
working in animation also but I'm
worried about the about whether the next
generation and following generations are
going to have any interest in or
patience with the artifact the artifact
of the book the artifact of the painting
or the freestanding sculpture I'm afraid
we're heading for kinds of cultural
wasteland if education does not get back
to basics okay and agree about a certain
line the historical line of an eye I
don't just believe in Western culture
being taught I am ulty culturalist
insofar as I believe we must have a kind
of global perspective in education but I
have said for 13 years now like a month
epoxy that we need to have a sense of
tradition history chronology things
moving down in time what the way kids
are being taught today is very a
historical thickest know nothing they've
never taught a date they have no sense
whatever everything is closer than the
present they have no sense of
the span of time or how large the world
is so I'm afraid that if I would say
television with very little television
please I think in education it's too
simple a crutch for teachers to gain
student attention from Quito Christensen
an email question to you we know from
all of your books that Katharine Hepburn
was an important influence on your
thinking and behavior do you have any
words on losing her even now Katharine
Hepburn was my first great role model I
would I saw a movie of hers on
late-night TV in Syracuse New York in
1959 I was 12 I became mad for her mad
for Hepburn why she was I don't I didn't
know what it was I thought what is it
what is this energy that's coming on for
I looked and realized it was a spirit of
these women of the 1920's 1930's that
had been lost in the post-war era of the
mississippi after you know after the
veterans came back and the baby blooming
and so on and so forth so i became
fixated on that period you know and we
now know i mean we didn't know at the
time that Katharine Hepburn's own mother
had been an ardent suffragette had been
a head of the Connecticut suffrage
association Hepburn herself had had
marched in in these parades of the child
giving out balloons Norman Sun and her
aunt was even more radical radical
feminist so I felt the feminist spirit
from captain Cameron leaping off that TV
screen these old movies and I
constructed a graph of all Hepburn films
ever made I got from the library and I
checked I tried to see them all and it
that time you couldn't get much
information about popular culture some
of the culture was still dismissed okay
so my passion interest in the media okay
was something in old Hollywood film was
something that I you didn't share it I
had no one is sure it was accepting gay
guys mean only gay guys were afforded
another thing so the Hepburn she was a
very long time but I absolutely agree
with people who are saying now that she
was one of the women of the century that
the but but she's not a woman who was a
mother she's not a woman who was able to
to to bridge the roles of the
professional woman with the woman who is
the it was really a more traditional
wife and mother I think it's very very
difficult that's a tremendous difficulty
I think facing women hits 11 resolve how
can the child is so
okay the child is this you know it once
as much attention as possible I don't
agree with the old feminist positions
that we need an endless government
daycare centers I I don't think that
that kind of warehousing of kids is the
right model I came out of an Italian
background where where children were
made enormous attention disagree with
the center of attention at the same time
is they were very disciplined okay so
the the military cultures in general
life latina culture today African
American culture is a very child
centered I think that that's we dance a
move away from that in feminism with the
infatuation with the career woman
through a very long period there San
Francisco
yes I just like to thank Camille for
having the courage to be herself
throughout his years thank you and my
question would be is what will it take
for society at large to see through the
illusions created by our singular
physical gender and into the dual sex
domain of the psyche and personality of
the individual well I believe that there
may be a problem here that is that it's
it's been realm of arsh is where one
explores the ambiguity of gender and
also the private realm that I've spoken
of earlier I'm not sure to what degree
we can export these ideas into the
public realm without disordering it and
I worry because as a student of history
I have seen that every time a culture
gets supposedly sophisticated and open
and tolerant toward alternate lifestyles
or homosexuality towards gay marriages
towards sex changes it's usually a
decadent culture that's on the verge of
collapse like ancient Rome so I I'm
worried about that as a question I'm
constantly asking in my book sexual
persona which the subtitle of witches
are in decadence okay from Nefertiti
student to Emily Dickinson I love
decadence by Meyer decadence as a
complex historical mode but I'm worried
okay I'm when conservatives speak about
the homosexual agenda they're right okay
when they speak about the permeation of
a fusion of our of the media with with
you know pro-gay slogans and program
messages there right okay and at a time
when knowledge of the Bible which I'm an
atheist I do not believe in it and that
the Bible is the Word of God the Bible
is a magnificent work of art one the
greatest ever created it is full of
messages of end and consolation for four
times of life okay where if trouble and
so on I worry about a culture where
where knowledge of the Bible is slipping
away even among the religious whereas we
have these trashy and it shows that our
entertaining would see about you know
Queer Eye for the straight guy and all
that kind of thing I mean they seem like
this is good this is progressive I worry
about a massive backlash because
Christianity rise of Christianity was
that backlash against reko Roman
paganism okay and it's now 2,000 years
later right the idea that a progressive
culture can sustain itself okay in this
kind of theatrical way flamboyant way
after all I dressed in my transvestite
Halloween costumes one day per year I
wasn't wearing it at wearing those
costumes every day it was going to set
Renee Lee and think I think that these
questions need to be asked much more by
people who are on the transgendered side
on the on the gay activist ID let's
study history study history right
nothing ever lasts and what comes after
you may be far worse than what you're
trying to reform right now how do you
feel about the growing anti-americanism
overseas oh this question oh this drives
me crazy I mean oh my god this is one
one of the one of my problems with the
incursion into Iraq right is this
tremendous inflammation of
anti-americanism around the world I
think this is a terrible legacy that has
come of this and I for example last year
this the Foreign Press tried to get me
repeatedly to to write things or to
comment to reporters about about the
about the prospect of war in Iraq I
refused okay I feel is wrong for
American intellectuals to to foment that
anti-american feeling that's already
abroad and so I finally did express my
feelings to David Talbott in an
interview for earlier this year for
salon but I mean I am highly
of intellectuals like Suzanne Stanton
who made a career a career of going
around the world you that you are fetid
okay you are you can be a you are claim
that the minute you saying anything
anti-american abroad way they people
will lay treasure your feet do that so
with the Dixie Chicks went over there
and what the Dixie Chicks have a right
to say whatever they want whenever they
want it okay but I don't think it was
right I don't think it was right for the
Dixie Chicks to say that in England at a
performance to get a good response from
the audience I want the district's come
back here okay and say it everywhere in
America and you're fine with that
I had a right to say it in England too
and they shouldn't be criticized for
that on the other hand people who want
to boycott them have also have a right
but I think that it's just there is a
deep anti-americanism in the way
communities are taught on campus I was
one the first people to raise this issue
by the way in my essay in junk bonds and
corporate raiders which which the
progressive editor Herbert Gold are
published in Orion is like a long as
it's in my first book second first is a
collection sex art in American culture
but I attack the anti-americanism of the
theorists who are so enamored of Michel
Foucault instead of I said that it's
something extremely wrong in fact in the
first chapter of sexual persona I also
say it is utterly hypocritical for our
intellectuals to be sneering at American
capitalism while enjoying all the
conveniences of American capital so now
my family came to America from the
poverty of southern Italy and I and we
all loved America in my family I have a
tremendous love of American ice and ice
but I think that what's happening now it
is in because with the Iraq issue
unresolved
it's a terrible kinds of a kind of
American boosterism I sort of all of
your forests are against us they're
coming out from conservative voices on
talk radio and it means people are not
unpatriotic for criticizing the Iraq war
it's not we do not pro Saddam ok
anti-bush ok by criticizing with the you
know government policy so I think that
the patron is an issue has become more
inflamed that anytime since since since
the Vietnamese war
well I want to get to this next caller
but there is another email air here says
do you think that broadcasting of your
social messages are fueling Islamism
Aslam
yours what darkness in mine is it's
using well I have written since you know
the early 90s I have talked about the
might my proposal for a reform of
education not just in America but on the
global stage was comparative religion I
believe that the religions you know I'm
an atheist I believe that the study of
world religions fear Christianity Islam
Hinduism and Buddhism at that's the key
towards a world understanding so I I'm
afraid ok
that's my confidence that in Islam was
shaken by the by the absence of
significant protest among is inner
Muslims in the year following the attack
on the World Trade Center I became very
uneasy by that I could not I found that
the enormous mass of Muslims are
peaceable they are peaceful but
obviously the way
Islam is constructed in this kind of non
hierarchical and non centralized way as
opposed to the Roman Catholic Church
that what you have is an intense and
inflamed minority getting the Islamists
aside who intended destruction what's a
civilization being essentially
uncontrolled within that religion so I
have become extremely uneasy about vibes
trends in Islam and again I'm someone
who reads history so I I look at things
in terms of 200 300 years cycles like a
history of Byzantium less on a few
hundreds of years of cycle and so I'm
looking down the road and down the road
I see our Iraq incursion ok as causing a
perpetuation of the kind of Islamic
terrorism that attacked the World Trade
Center and I I don't I don't think that
this was the way to go to put our tanks
into Baghdad okay I don't think was the
way to defuse the anti-americanism in
Islamic fundamentalism now let's get to
that phone call San Antonio thank you
for waiting go ahead you're on with
Camille Polly a doctor partner yes let's
get to say I love you you're my favorite
columnist there's a Hunter Thompson's
Orson Scott Card
Rush Limbaugh on you thanks but ever
since the you sub render for Lana
no idea where to read you right now well
I what do you what are you doing
I guess the regular column well I think
thank you very much for your remarks I I
just found it something I need to write
books okay so I'm currently finishing a
book on poetry for Pantheon books I've
been running for three years I feel I
feel it's really important for me to go
back to books but I'm writing an
occasional column for for Interview
magazine where I am a contributing
editor but you know occasionally I do
things like this Hillary in a book
review and so on but I'm afraid that you
know thank you very much Russell may say
about Rush Limbaugh yes I special envoy
you know his views mine are quite
different particularly I recently bought
the Iraq war and son I respect him as
independent voice I think that the the
definition of Rush Limbaugh by liberals
and by the Democratic Party is atrocious
because it is that this is a man who
created an entire program items managed
to say either person the kafir came from
the Midwest who sticks to his own
independent-minded this or this this
very active imagination of his managed
to created an empire for himself and he
and he - he is no stooge for any group
he's independent man yes now he's
relaxed a little more who's joining golf
clubs you know that's good more power
than he deserves you know to rest more
but I think I have gotten so much
pleasure I've done more its intellectual
stimulation from listening to Rush
Limbaugh often when I'm driving my car
then then then all those theorists and a
khadeem Aryan people can read you there
now yes
now you another example from the viewer
yes here is my most recent essay which
is it's called pulse and cosmic
consciousness religious vision in the
American 1960s is a cover story of the
the most of this of a winter issue of
Orion again I and I feel immense and I
think well I think it's herb or gold or
is the editor it's a it's a classic
journal Journal of classes and
humanities at the Boston University and
in this essay I speak of the hope that
the web web link will be available to
the viewers so that they can read this
very very long article it's an overview
of the 16th from the point of view of
religion if I feel that this is one one
aspect of the 60s that is too much
neglected conservatives attached to 60s
with you know it whatever kind of a
cudgel and I think that they're missing
the spiritual impulse that them I think
motivated so many of the people that I
remember from from that era I feel but
it's been a model I mean the New Age
movement that is the result is a
terrible model it's a new a New Age
movement has tried to revise your dear
Christianity by removing the
judgmentalism the anti sex you know
aspects of it but I think that people
are lost I think that Western culture is
it's not in great shape it's not in
great shape many of the worst things
said about it by by Islamic
fundamentalist are aren't that true
people are questing questing for their
sexual identity questing for for for
personal relationships in perhaps ways
that none of those so two things can
sustain I mean maybe we need to return
to the great fundamentals in order to do
to the study of nature the study of
great books I mean the study of religion
so that's why I feel that that even even
though I don't believe in God I believe
in nature I feel that the world
religions are great complex symbol
systems far more interesting and
illuminating sustaining that anything
produced by European post-structuralism
or post-modernism and that this intent
whenever I teach talk about religion to
students no matter what background they
come from they're craving at those
thirsty the kids today are thirsty
they're wondering this utterly being no
media environment with these trashy
shows we're not in the period of great
Hollywood anymore we're not in a period
of great stars anymore even Madonna is
on a decline I mean there hasn't been a
a major star performance and Sharon
Stone in Basic Instinct 1992 okay so
we're wanting this desert wasteland of
enough media people are just in look
like I mean we look a hedonistic you
know of you know materialistic
empty-headed imperialist people abroad I
can understand the anti Americanism
that's happening we've just got to pull
ourselves out of this you can see that
website on your screen right now that
command Polly was talking about and you
can go to it at WWE u GD u /o Ryan next
call for her is San Diego yes hi I hate
to burst the love fest here and while I
respect you as the most rational
of sort of conservative point of views
I've heard on c-span here it's just um
swelled with so many falsehoods this is
your interpretation I'm in
anthropological archaeologists so of
course I learned history I don't know
what you're talking about it University
that's all we learn is history and I
teach fundamentals I teach basic writing
and what I have are a bunch of
conservative kids and you're right they
don't know history but they certainly
they have some longing for a traditional
path that there's conservative
Republican parents have taught them that
never existed I mean first of all back
to your gender roles this is so I'm glad
your ancestors we're good with their
hands what does that say about men
that's absurd second of all it's an
anthropologist if you look around the
world gender roles are specific and you
should know this as a historian that our
gender roles are specific to a
post-industrial revolution America they
are not shared if you go to notch a and
the Philippines the women are using
bones and arrows if you go to the market
in Africa the a zombie women are the
toughest minded women you'll ever see
our gender roles are specific to our
time in more places this ridiculous
thing about gender roles women are it is
so historically and culturally down in
Americans part of white people hate it
is we think our way is the only way
because we don't have any sense of
ourselves and that it was different and
that before the Industrial Revolution
gender roles were different and it's
totally changed over time and the other
thing in this idea of progress there is
no such thing that is why Darwin did not
publish his book what he was afraid of
wasn't that we evolved from apes what he
was afraid of is the implication that
there is no such thing as progress
things just change that's what I learn
as an archaeologist what is a constant
in archaeology is not the ideology but
elites manipulating ideology in order to
control people and what I'm worried
about is this idea of fundamentals what
your what fundamentals I keep hearing
about traditional values is that linking
black people that's a traditional
American value is that what we want
San Diego thank you oh well I'm not sure
why she was disagreeing with me because
everything she said after the lynching
part I agreed with absolutely everything
I think I think absolutely clear that I
that I've talked about the the way
gender roles have changed radically from
for example the 1920s and 30s
well the Katharine Hepburn Amelia
Earhart era was quite different than the
social role being imposed on me the
gender role in the 1950s oh my gosh yes
these things are very much in flux
nevertheless in my work I do believe
that there is a some basis in in biology
for for gender roles and in my book
sexual persona begins with the the Venus
the Venus of Willendorf which is a cult
object found in Austrian sight that
based perhaps from 25,000 years BC and I
talked about what this very obese object
which is blind was with was hardly it
like sort of flipper arms and no see
what that means about the image of woman
understanding a woman that was projected
at a time of the survivalist life where
people were desperate for in times of
famine and for food and so on and then I
in sexual personally I go on to the the
bust of Nefertiti and look at ad
division of woman that had was
transformed in Egyptian aristocratic
society where all of a sudden now we
don't have the large breasts of the
Venus of Willendorf or that like milk
sex whereas the small elegant breasts of
these of the upper-class women so it
ends that what I call the birth of the
Western I where we there's a migration
from from the from the solar plexus to
the to the I into to this to this
projection that's what Western culture
has been brilliant at just the
projection of ambition and illusion and
yes the delusion of progress Western
culture has had been has been diluted
with the idea of progress going to start
wars Hinduism does not believe in that
it leaves them the great wheel of
reincarnation things moving so I mean
actually I just hardly anything I do
agree with them and then in that color
Alexandria Virginia I professor Paul II
I've enjoyed hearing your ideas for many
years I especially enjoyed
on c-span a speech you gave the
geopolitical Union several years ago
where you talked about the changes in
name of storms from just female names to
including both male and female names I
thought that was hilarious but more
importantly you've identified yourself
as a libertarian but then you also have
said that you voted for the Clintons
twice and you've identified yourself as
a member of the Democratic Party and I
wonder with so many libertarians or
people that believe that people should
make their own choices unhindered by
government how those people have mainly
gravitated towards the Republican Party
although obviously there's a split with
the religious right why you identify
yourself with the Democratic Party
ah thank you so much that wonderful
question because I I did not belong to
the libertarian Society in many
libertarians are indeed rather
conservative it's because I believe in
this sharp demarcation of the public
versus private realm but I believe that
there should be a safety net for the for
the poor and the weak I believe there
are legitimate areas for government
activity I think that in the area of
public clinics of off people's roads and
so on I do believe that in the shrinking
of government I believe that we that we
have a sprawling government bureaucracy
that survives administrations doesn't
matter whether it's a Republican or
Democrat in this in the White House we
have this endless number of laws laws
and more laws I think there has to be a
kind of Gordian knot a cutting way down
in terms of regulations of intrusion to
people's lives on the other hand I am
well aware from the Industrial
Revolution on of the tendency of
capitalism that which I believe in
because I believe that capitalism has
produced a modern independent woman the
woman who is no longer dependent on
father or her husband okay for her for
her sustenance but I do believe that
capitalism is Darwinian and that that
government regulation government
oversight is necessary one of my
favorite poems that worked so well in
class like I've talked about in social
persona is William Blake's chimney-sweep
poem where you see the atrocity of child
labor and the that's the short lives of
these poor children that were made to go
up the chimneys and to inhale that
carcinogenic dust and so on it's only
government action which was debated
for decades and to what degree did
government have the right to come in to
regulate a private industrial workplace
it was a huge argument it went on for
like 4050 years and in England so I do
feel that as that there's this kind of
dynamic going on in modern industrial
agriculture and that is that is we have
I believe in entrepreneurship I believe
that the vitality of business is on but
what we have today would have sprawling
you know a you know a global kind of
corporate entities and this and the the
there's a kind of definitely
fossilization happening in the very
mechanism that was invented in the
industrial revolution in england has
produced so much wealth and has produced
our high standards of living so I think
that again there is a role for
government a great role for government
but but I do not believe in the big
government solution or the endless the
micromanaging of social policy okay
bye-bye spy which is endorsed by so many
members of democratic parties our
emailer Patricia Roy wants to know what
you think of William F Buckley Jr was
walk with jr. well I respect him as a
great mind originally okay but I think
that wasn't much but once he I think one
once he was like he was such a
controversial list and he was such a he
was such a an opposer to current
orthodoxies beginning when in his
college career at Yale and so on so I
really respect him but I feel that by
the time the 90s came around when I came
on the scene okay that I wish that he
had been a more active in the reform of
campus politics I feel that he would
make a kind of lordly allusions to the
matter and in a dismissive manner on his
show but I became rather vexed over the
peer of the nineties I felt that if he
had used his way to really you know wade
into the issues that we wouldn't have
this kind of lost generation which we
have today I mean that you know in
humanities situation is a disaster on
college campuses some of our most you
know brilliant and promising young
people who did not go into the
humanities were driven out of the
graduate school in the last 15 years so
we have a period now or trying to
recuperate it so the best the greatest
activity that's been done in reform has
been done by David Horowitz on his site
front in front page magazine.com I mean
David Horowitz has done more in the last
three years okay to to prod along campus
reform than William F Buckley did
throughout that period of the 90s when
he when he should have been you know
full you know full cultural I am
Philadelphia Valley is home city hi dr.
paglia it's a it's a permanent honor to
speak to you thank you I at the few
years back during the OJ Simpson murder
trial you made a comment about the 911
recording that Nicole Simpson had made
and your comment if you I hope you
remember it was that what you were
listening to what you were hearing was a
woman playing a game you heard it mm-hmm
and I found it so interesting because
you know up until the time I hadn't
really considered her role if you will
in her own demise however minor it might
be and I was wondering if you could
either expand on that specifically or
maybe just about women in abusive
relationships in general well I think
one doesn't want to blame the victim in
any situation with an atrocity is
committed are they I believe the death
penalty by the way and my point - I
believe that you know anyone who commits
to the atrocious murder or particularly
you know torture murders of children
these people should be executed as I am
in my opinion so I'm not excusing the
assailant whoever it was in this case
although somebody must have suspected
was AJ himself I have said that that
that was an example of this when the
police are starting to be drawn in to
private relationships whether through
restraining orders okay or E or whatever
where your fear you call it making 911
no one calls what you have then is a
combat that starts to be a competition
between the man and the police okay I
think that women actually end up
endangering themselves further by this
because the may end up getting killed
sometimes because the man wants to
defeat the police I'll show you I can
get to her that kind of thing so I think
that that what we need much more of is a
sense of psychology oddly enough
psychology despite all of our talk shows
you know they're always talking about
personal relationships and so on a real
psychological analysis seems to me to be
receding over the last can
year we need I think much more talking
about relationships what what do people
look for in sex I think there's a lot of
symbolism in sex so what what are people
seeking for when you have an unstable
relationship religion has been abusive
and it was with Nicole since of course
she was young when they started going
together
the young Nicole but his abusiveness to
her his controlling of her him pushing
her around physically was was an item
already in that relationship my my
attitude is if someone does something to
you now it's going to continue don't
think you're ever going to acure that
that there is a a process of a
psychological need and control in
certain men that I have analyzes having
something to do with the mother complex
okay some it's some shadowy game that a
man is playing with the poor the wife or
lover as proxy for his problems with it
was a feeling you're over controlled or
his identity obliterated by an older
generation I think that there's a lot of
these questions of psychology operating
in gay identity too but you haven't
forbid anyone should mention anyone can
know there is such a thought police
right now on this question okay for 20
years you can I ask any questions okay
about the psychological development of
either gay or actually heterosexual
identity that's off the table right now
the only problems for anyone are I help
on a pressive public system that needs
to be revised but many of these it is
being in these inner ambiguities and
people in a drive are illuminated by art
art is the best way to to actually
discover who you are in my view okay it
is not through passing more regulations
having the police come in and in create
order in a relationship that is unstable
Mesa Arizona yes my question is about
gun rights I loved what Miss Pylea wrote
about in so on a couple of years ago
that the right to bear arms is a
protection against the tyranny of
government and because governments
always tend to exploit and abuse people
and the only thing that's protecting us
is the the protection of individual gun
rights and I have a second question as
well and I formulated this as I was
listening waiting on Ryan and that was
you said that since Sharon Stone there's
no being no real big breakout star may I
suggest that in
the recent movie swimming pool looted
beam Sonnier is somebody to take a look
at I don't know if you've seen that
movie I haven't had a chance I sure
welcome well she's French of course and
naturally non-american if it shows that
perhaps the European culture is
revitalizing itself yes yes I do I don't
I don't own guns I'm not interesting
guns but all my uncle's you hunt they
have a right to have guns no matter how
liberals want to dice and slice it I
believe that that it is very clearly
stated in our Bill of Rights that there
is a right to bear arms now that does
not mean of course that people should be
having assault weapons okay and having
stockpiles of weapons in an urban
environment I'm not sure exactly how to
approach this except to to to
restabilizing social structure of the
inner cities I think it I think we can't
be intruding into the rights of
law-abiding gun owners outside the urban
centers merely because of you know of
pathologies that that are have nothing
whatever to do with guns actually
there's an emailer here who says have
you noticed that all of your colors are
male I think he's wrong I think there
were two females so far but he says how
much of your following how much of your
following is mail as opposed to female I
haven't noticed it's usually men who
like to call I mean men like to call
there's like this no may I begin time
counted I've gotten a lot of letters
over the years from from women who
particularly the ones I just mentioned
that were driven out of graduate school
want to go into the humanities and then
and just could not swallow that there's
diets of totally useless and jargon
choked post structuralism that they were
at they're forced to to study instead of
real literature and art but I think that
you know when I came on the scene in in
1990 okay I was speaking for four men in
a way that hadn't been done I mean that
Warren Farrell in his book the myth of
male power a former member of now
actually it was writing about these
issues but but you know very few other
people down Christina Hoff Sommers was
out in the in the late 1980s when I was
so unpublished camera publish she was
out there boldly challenging feminist
rhetoric in so many areas and she
deserves a lot of credit for having
initiated a you know so much of the
reform that have happened
this happened yeah I think very well
within within feminism but no one was
saying a good word about men okay at all
and I thought it was ridiculous
at the point I was always making was
that the world that we women enjoy now
that allows us to be to be free and
independent career is right was created
by men it's a huge invisible structure
in so many of the upper middle-class
professionals don't even notice the kind
of physical labor that goes into the
production of their space okay that
people who are who are laying the roof
you note are doing all the dirty work
who are the plumbers in the you know the
people who who are who are doing the
construction of you know of our of our
physical environment so coming out of an
immigrant family that was originally
working-class my family came to work in
the Endicott Johnson shoe factories and
upstate New York I tend to have a a more
positive view of Industry okay it also
by the way this is it so it doesn't
something from a prior color I have a
view of enlightened capitalism too
because the the Johnson family they were
the owners of the Endicott Johnson shoe
factory but leading taking care of the
workers there with free medical care
there was a help with housing we and
there was a strike freight cars full of
citrus fruits cents up from from there
in Florida about whatever every winter
and so on I thought this is there's a
kind of caring personal relationship
that the Johnson family had with it with
their with her immigrant Italian
speaking for the most part workers I
thought it was a kind of model of what
what an enlightened businessman you know
should be behaving like I think Oakland
California we all to find you here on a
Sunday morning Camila I when I first
heard you and when I started reading
your books just during my blood the
blood flowing between my ears here and I
think it um born in America and being a
native English speaker I've learned to
appreciate a little Italian through
music study and film and I'm wondering
if you've had any occasion to use it in
your research or just casually and have
your works been translated into Italian
and how are they received and you have
any favorite Italian movies oh my god
there's so many questions there okay let
me a favor Italian movies I don't know
about the current telling movies like my
favorite ones go like la dolce vita
eight and a half and
some monica bedi in love into ah it
moved like the great classics of art
film but yes my workshop and it
translated into italian I'm treated well
I'm a kind of I guess icon in certain
areas like I've written quite a bit for
Corriere della Sera when I when I came
on the scene it was at the same time as
Madonna was becoming this world
phenomenon and we were often tied linked
together because I would kind of explain
our explicator of Madonna at the time
her background is Italian American oh
very similar to mine I I certainly
thought use Italian in terms of opera I
mean II is a huge influence on me I was
listening to Puccini operas throughout
my the writing of my Emily Dickinson
chapter actually in in sexual persona
actually this music I different music
for different chapters we actually for
my book I'm very influenced by but by
music my my it's my my two sides the
family spoke different dialects in in my
childhood my mother's family comes from
a small town called Chicano in last year
about 20 miles north of Monte Cassino
and they speak chicken AIDS it's
completely different than the Napa Latin
dialects spoken abide my my pala side
grandmother who came from the small
towns inland Benevento Caserta and so on
so I actually in my childhood a lot so
much is body language okay in childhood
I think it's one reason why I have such
a long instinctive understanding of
dancers and why I have such a rapport
with dancers it dance teachers and the
whole dance school in my own school that
stump there's a way that it's has you
live in their body I think that's almost
it's the Nitza level of language Marissa
and Silver Spring wants to know what you
think of Sopranos I love The Sopranos
I'll work at warpath work as I joined
the National Italian American Foundation
and protest against the Sopranos like I
am I'm active also now with the order of
the Sons of Italy that actually had its
um headquarters in Endicott right next
to my own grandmother's sub house there
I love The Godfather films I thought
they were masterpieces i revered Mario
Puzo I interviewed him actually for the
New York Times so on but the soprano I
load the reason being and has to do I
think not only for the way it portrays
italian-american
buffoon but the way if our Trey's
working-class life I think this upon us
is wildly out-of-date actually has to do
with a 1960s style of North's birthday
not nineteen late 1980s was ninety nine
to nineteen ninety and I coming I teach
in Philadelphia now you know and there
is a style okay that working-class
people have a self expression right die
Feliz character on that show okay I feel
that show is a favorite of upper
middle-class viewers or almost things
are getting an anthropological
perspective is something that doesn't
exist anymore and in fact is being is a
being is a cartoon the cartoon vision I
I've tried to watch I haven't gone
through a whole program okay I try to
watch it okay and I become furious after
good I know many people who are who are
great fans of the show so I don't want
to you know my take on it shouldn't
influence anyone else in this or in
anything
Chicago Thank You sexual persona which I
read for the first time when I was in
high school I'm 24 years old now and
then I reread as I was studying in
Florence Italy sitting under the great
Duomo was the central formative text I
think of my intellectual development and
I'm happy to hear you focusing again on
writing books and I think that much more
than columns the book is really the
right genre for your ideas which have
always been on a grand scale thank you
um along with sexual persona is a junk
bonds and corporate raiders was
essential in my decision not to attend
graduate school in the humanities but
rather to study law which is a
profession in which I think honorable
men and women can still adjust the
intellect to real questions of society
as you know thinkers of the Italian
Renaissance and and Montaigne and people
like that did in the past the question
is given the current situation in
academia especially in the humanities
where should intelligent young people
today direct their energy thank you I
think actually that the theory boom
thank God is waning that I feel that you
think that situation is much better than
it was in 1991 when junk bonds and
corporators was published that by the
way that is a long piece and we don't
incident have if it's in sex art in
American culture it is a very long piece
that that the sex two books that Ryan
sent me to review about they were by two
gay academics
Fuko admirers of classical antiquity I
was shocked when I actually read them
when I saw the trashing of the all the
generations of great scholars who had
come before and who had like done is
back-breaking work to put together all
these great additions and gathered all
this archaeological information and I
was being thrown out the window by these
trendy careerists are going from
conference to conference so when I came
on the scene in the early 1990s lack
Hall dairy dying for coal we're like god
Jared I was slightly disappointed fade
because he had been revealed as a Nazi
sympathizer oh I love that I but but
like all was deeply entrenched in
feminism and Foucault was like a god all
right so I would after them and I and I
show in that piece as I stand behind
today I think it's a search today of all
the insufficiencies in the thinking of
it particularly Foucault but I think
that everybody knows now that parently
even the new york times of reporting
recently that there was a whole glum
conference of a con fab theorists who
got together and who said we're now with
her now fury is over where are we going
to go on our way yeah you trashed a
khadeem you trash that's a great art and
literature k was diminished and only for
undergraduate who went through but in
the eyes of the nation and now you we
have this a wasteland okay I'm seeing of
the humanities again only didn't happen
in the sciences okay and not in history
proper in too much except in the most PC
places but now I think it's actually a
good moment and perhaps for graduate
students to start rethinking about the
humanities and it my mantra is always
hate dogma I hate Dogma I do not accept
done with many including me okay I've
seen myself I'm simply a free thinker
okay that's what I'm saying do not solve
indeed arm of any institution any body
of theory okay you must respond yourself
to great literature and art I think we
can I think the thing will be
reconstructed but Harrell Bloom said on
this very program he doesn't think it's
going to happen in his lifetime and it
may not happen in my lifetime but I'm
convinced the humanities will rebound
everything always rebounds in the long
in the long run I think the colleges are
in a period now retrenchment are the an
obscene period of course of extravagant
you know tuition charges by the major
universities I mean an enormous scam but
the major media has ignored and a
scandal bankrupting middle-class
families right so there's going to be a
period of retrenchment being
reported now all kinds of cutbacks at
Stanford a Duke at Bryn Mawr and so on
so I think after we go through this
period of him what I'm worried about is
the humanities have been marginalized
the humanities have shown themselves
worthless with it when I entered
graduate school in 1968 poetry and
literature and art we're at the high
point of prestige what did the
humanities departments do of an America
okay to trash that and no no one cares
what goes on on campus great no one
believes that a literature in our very
interest thanks to the mishandling of
these issues okay back on campus so
anyway I would encourage young people
who are watching this is a good moment
okay to enter into into important to put
your impress your interpretation on the
whole cultural tradition I think there
is a great feature in teaching include
if only we could liberate the public
schools okay Oh
all these unemployed PhDs and mas and
humanities what we can't employ them in
the public schools okay why because of
the you know this terrible parasitic
teacher union thing and you've got to
have an education degree if a worthless
education degree okay okay put the PhDs
to work in the classroom for heaven's
sakes our inner cities our schools are a
mess scandal Utah you said next year
will be 20 years 20 years and readers of
the arc this title is actually a fairly
recent one we would if it was a merger
of the Philadelphia College of Art with
the Philadelphia College of Performing
Arts in the late 80s and both of those
institutions go all the way back to the
19th century in terms of their
forerunners see where the art school was
associated with the Philadelphia Museum
okay Andy and there was a conservatory
are funded by musicians foreign
composers from from lipstick okay they
was the Philadelphia musical Academy so
this is the incarnation now that's
expanded into all kinds of areas that
would jag and jazz dance you know
animation all kinds of things before
that at Bennington I was at Bennington
play my first job for eight years or
1970s and I got into one problem after
another I was still I was in a state of
delusion still I was a sick I didn't
take drugs in the 60s I don't take drugs
I'm against drugs I don't believe in
sophisticated use of alcohol with meals
this is what I believe but I was an
equally a state of delusion I don't know
what what what dementia we 60s people
were in ok bite so I did one stupid
thing after another at Bennington I had
a wonderful experience there are
brilliant students some of whom I saw
have like Heidi John Schmidt with a
writer and novelist her novel is coming
out of the bride of catastrophe from
Picador and in a few months I just
Kristen Lippincott was now the now the
director of the of the Greenwich
Observatory Museum in London and so on
so I had creative students at Bennington
it was it was a wonderful time but
everyone's mad It was as if madness
after the 60s you know one of your
detractors said you left there after a
fistfight yeah oh no I said it oh yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah well it's a
long story
okay it's a very long story but yes
there's a culminating instant but there
was only one of them every couple of
years of some big thing okay like where
I I kicked the student in the rear end
and the feminist students gave me the
award the golden boot you know for I
mean it's a long it was one drama after
another finally there was a fistfight at
a dance now I was too young what was i
doing at the dance okay I shouldn't be
there it isn't but it Bennington there
were no ranks and it's you know
everything's just like we call by your
first name and everything was very like
so yeah I mean that's so there was a
culminating drama okay I was always a
very physical person I've learned a lot
about life with one of the big things I
learned it but I feel I grew up at
Bennington
I really do a first job and one of the
big lessons I learned is that
institutions change slowly and that if
you if you want to affect change it is
true of government - okay it must be
incremental change that by that we have
a 60s were too impatient and that we had
this we were this narcissistic
megalomaniacal idea that change would
happen overnight and that we were the
one to do it
this kind of ostensibly left you know
that we had and so the most brilliant
minds that I knew they all screwed up
they also put through drugs or through
misjudgments or they died of AIDS or
whatever okay so I feel that some of the
with some the greatest points of view of
the 60s never found the book they never
got as far as leaving the book leaving
something for posterity
which i think is it's very important you
cannot just 60 singers experience
experience be experienced now you can't
just be an experience which is what
you're taught actually in buddhism or
even hinduism okay I said in the Western
tradition okay there is this this this
impulse this proposal to create
something that will last
nothing's going to
nothing will last but this impulse to
create the thing that we hope will last
has I think produced our kind of
pyramiding achievements that is one of
the great glories of the West Oakland
California you're next with Camille
Talia go ahead Oakland oh yes I have a
question
love your work thank you I'm interested
in your take on an exclusively male
organization like the Hells Angels
Motorcycle Club and a leader like Sonny
Barger
whoa-ah oh well getting everything why
well the Hells Angels were such oh they
were likely with tremendous culture
icons to us women in the 1960 perhaps
excessively of course that hold
motorcycle ethos was looking launched
for us by Marlon Brando's of appearance
in the in the wild one which had which
you know which had had its roots and
some sort of held early Hells Angels
incident that happened in a town 1948 or
something in Northern California if I
remember correctly but the image of
Brando on with his motorcycle and his
leather jacket was on posters on our
wall so you know at that time well I
mean I the Hells Angel singer is like
it's so American sort of be free they're
like Vikings you know Vikings in the
open air they don't think of course the
disastrous error made by the Rolling
Stones and having them be security
guards for the for the rock concert of
Altamont its chronicles of course and
Gimme Shelter anyone that hasn't seen
that movies must I don't think that the
Hells Angels are model okay for for
social developments because they're so
isolationist and you know anarchic
they're they're kind of a tribal unit a
ninja of course it's not the same the
today's Hells Angels is a far more
genteel organization than it once was
but they will live forever in terms of
American cultural model even for the for
the world at large I think the ability
the motorcycle used to be for Europeans
quite a quite a proper and a kind of our
official bike used by by military
officers and so on
but it was Americans it's through Hells
Angels who turned that the motor the
motor bike into the hog until kind of a
modern horse moving over the open plains
there are people who might find this
picture of you or just a graphic of you
they might not appreciate it and or they
may not like it and so I'm going to tell
them that
ahead of time in case they don't want to
see it but this comes from one of your
books you mentioned marlon brando we're
talking about motor so this was the
graph this was a picture of you
the caricature of you rather that was
that was not allowed to be put in a San
Francisco Examiner how did this come
about how did this caricature come about
well well it is back turn home did this
I guess they were doing a profile of me
or something in this emphysema examiner
he did this and he I guess there are I
haven't didn't say sexual devices yet
for handlebars and it was not correct
yeah okay there it is okay and they
found that it was not suitable for a
family newspaper okay but it's a
wonderful caricature and I told him I
would like to put it in a future book of
mine oh there it is Raleigh North
Carolina well dr. Paul you it seems that
one of the most needed things in early
education pre-collegiate education is
greener emphasis on developmental
psychology things that there's systems
are not being taught Bloom's taxonomy
and math Wow and things like they have
to help them order the lives and their
education you comment on that and
comment well in that light it seems that
well maybe we don't need so much history
early on that history is really an
advanced kind of thing to study well I'm
not sure what can you tell me you're
saying that developmental psychology is
being neglected in what would area were
in your experience where in grade school
in grade school one of the teachers you
mean students aren't taught it and
parents haven't been taught it so
they're not able to take control of
education as well as they should
mm-hmm well I mean a couple of things
yeah I think that a lot many there's a
lot of problems in American life in
terms of I think that children are
arriving at school with discipline
problems are not that the school should
not have to deal with I think that the
schools are you know of my parents day
were a much firmer in preserving an
orderly environment so that the working
class kids could could learn and then so
I think also that parents are not taking
responsibility for what they can impart
to the child before the child ever
reaches even preschool on that debate
my education really is my parents
reading to me we didn't have any money
if everything my father was still in
college when I wouldn't not when I was
born my parents simply read to me and I
think that that is absolutely crucial
particularly in this in this modern
media age that he asked what was the
second question I'm sorry the you know
that's it sorry the second one was oh no
I do it something they want I want to
get to actually first oh dear oh dear
dance day it happens every once in a
while dear I think of it we'll come back
hopefully we'll come back - I'm so sorry
Nevada California yes hello
I admire your books and my husband is a
fan of yours and he's the one that
recommended I read your book he loved
them I wanted to question you about the
feeling of the mass cultural Idol as it
were and you mentioned Madonna than
Sharon Stone and I want to put forth a
new candidate for the younger generation
Jennifer Lopez she has her own industry
money she's a sexual icon for the
younger generation she's in
relationships with men that when they
don't suit her she doesn't like him
she's gone
and also the movies that she did were
very powerful for women for instance
Selena and the movie enough where she
gets Marshall training and defends
herself as you have said on the program
earlier is what women need to do so I
wondered what your thoughts were on
Jennifer Lopez well I have been
following her career since Selena I
thought Selena was up what a piece of
work that is a piece of acting I'm a
little disappointed that the kind of the
look that she projects now is a little
bit bleached out I mean I like that very
very sort of sun-ripened Latin look that
she had in Selena what Oh her emotional
range and that in that film as well as
her dance moves are just simply
sensational
I loved her early albums I think that's
part of the problem now is that she's
becoming a diva we do need divas I mean
as cher is approaching the end of her
your long run and and so on
it's really quite hilarious yes the way
that Jennifer Lopez seems to be in total
total control of men and has is now a
spokesperson for so many products
I think she may be hitting a rough patch
though right now is the same one that
maybe Madonna I hit her but her once in
her current movies is getting a slam the
new movie was it was Ben Affleck Julie
or whatever it is I'm afraid getting
some of the worst reviews of you know
probably of the year well no we have to
remember Madonna's swept away was
equally a terrible disaster but yeah I
think that Jennifer Lopez yes she is a
New York she's a you know from being
from the Bronx
she definitely projects that
street-smart feminism that I was talking
about in the early 90s and advancing
transept thank you for that question
here's a caricature of Camille Paglia as
diva in the Harvard Gay and Lesbian
review of 1994 from one of your books
question from Leigh Martinez email
question what do you think of President
Bush's re-election chances well as a
Democrat I think disappointing me I
think is chance but wishes trends are
very good because I don't think that the
Democrats are going to be able to show
that they can be relied on for security
in military issues and this is something
that I have for 10 years been talking
about in the beginning of a 90s I have
criticized the domestic preoccupation
obsession of the Democratic Party in
particularly of the women politicians
who were so involved in caretaking
issues that when in fact the commander
in chief and I am so committed to the
idea of getting a woman into the White
House a to be commander-in-chief you
have to command the Armed Forces and so
the one thing we should be preparing our
ambitious young women for from the 70s
to the 80s to the 90s is military
history and betrayal instead that was
completely neglected okay in this
anti-war anti-military anti-american
bias of the of the elite universities
so right now therefore there's this
vacuum in the Democratic Party we have
carry who does have you know his
experience with Vietnamese war but then
he became a protester against the war
after that I mean are there any one of
these people that you wouldn't you that
said even though I said Democrats say
that I would you know give the security
of the nation over into it's quite
despite all my criticisms and I have
many of the Republican administration
okay for including the I feel our
intrusions into civil liberties by John
Ashcroft I still feel that a high profit
that the voters are going to say okay
who are you going to feel safer with in
the White House and this cage of
terrorism okay President Bush or one of
the one of the twelve Dwarfs what is the
best thing that George Bush has done as
president in opinion
President Bush has restored dignity to
the White House okay which was treated
like Animal House like a frat house by
the president I have to help to relax by
Bill Clinton all those those young
twerps to pay going in there and
behaving I mean the picture on the front
of a National Enquirer of the Clintons
friends
bouncing with their feet on the Lincoln
bed in the Lincoln Bedroom okay a
disgrace okay those people did not take
seriously okay what the all gust nature
of the mission of the presidency and I
think that that's one thing and I love
the way the one thing I love is the way
the President Bush doesn't care about
socialites doesn't care about the
immediate bigwigs doesn't care about how
those celebrities the curtain is always
schmoozing with the Hollywood
celebrities okay in a way that's servile
and the president United States the
first lady should not have been so
servile to the Hollywood elite and I
love Hollywood I'm a great admirer of
Hollywood I think they should know their
place again the great scene missing New
York City hi dr. pol yeah it's an honor
to speak with you
hi um thank you for your master works I
miss your salon columns that we should
bring them back if you could comment on
two things one when your follow-up to
sexual facade I will be out and the Kobe
Bryant case whoo well the second volume
of sexual persona which is a popular
culture has been sitting in a box since
1981 when both volumes were done for the
first time I took forever to get to get
the first volume into print and now I
mean now it clearly if both volumes had
come out in 1990 yo Chris couldn't have
done that you need a wheelbarrow okay
this is already a 700 page book the
Volume one
I now so much else has happened that I
need to you know I'm rethinking the
volume too because I no longer am quite
the Evangelist of popular culture that I
was in 1981 or even 1990 because of this
of the precipitous decline in quality of
popular culture so I
realize that my blogging too when it
comes out will have a very elegiac cast
to it it's not it's not what I would
hope and then that second decimal Kobe
Bryant oh the puppy pregnant well I you
know I I'm not sure obviously the facts
of the case no one does know right but
it has been interesting to see that it
is from the very start the the automatic
belief in kobe bryant's view of it
rather than this girl's view of it in
the media and I thought what a reversal
was since the time of a 1989-1990 when
we had all those like this with date
rape cover stories and people and Larry
King was having date rape victims on the
show and so on I thought that's very
interesting but you know whether or not
this girl
it has mental problems okay is
irrelevant to whether or not an assault
occurred in that room and we wouldn't
move must wait the facts of the case but
I will say this that anyone who has has
stranger sex whether they're straight or
like Kobe Bryant or they're gay men or
whatever anyone you pick up a stranger
okay you are importing right up next to
your body they every kind of psychodrama
in that person's head and you know what
what they are you don't know if they're
a nice murder or a deranged person so
Kobe Bryant has been made a seriousness
judgment that's pretty obvious no matter
what here because I believe that his you
know his commercial endorsements at
least are certainly in serious jeopardy
if not already dead as a doornail
Ferdinand ISIF Cleveland wants to know
how you feel about iron ran writing on
people have often asked me about iron
ran it is the people have people notice
its similarity I never actually read her
in in college when her great period was
actually nineteen fifty people in
nineteen fifties who are Justin beat
writing and they were kind of bohemian
we're very into Iran
so I heard her name and then when I came
on the scene in the 90s all of a sudden
she was back again and people began
asking me and I think that I bet so then
I actually looked at her work I went oh
my god there are passages in Iran that
sounds like my writing and it sound like
sexual persona I went this is so
interesting I think the thing is that
her influences were similar to mine that
is she was very interested in the
romantic writers she was she liked it
what was she I think she absorbed
Nietzsche in many ways but that's the
difference between me and Iran she
believes in a strong individual but I
believe in in government I don't just
believe in the individualist going out
and being able to be all things into
into the world I mean I do believe that
the government has a role to protect the
prime not just Darwinian say go the poor
and the weak have to have just a false
ID and another thing is that Iran like
Simone de Beauvoir is a rationalist okay
and I don't just believe in the power of
a rational mind I believe in the power
of dreaming of imagination of art I
believe in the irrational and and
there's a kind of bias that I ran in
someone de Beauvoir had against religion
I take religion very seriously I think I
think it is the most the most both fully
developed of all in the comprehensive
views of the universe that the human
being said yet yet produced so I am NOT
I don't have a dismissive quality Simone
de Beauvoir and Iran were very
disdainful of people who were religious
and felt that they were like weaklings
okay that should get over it okay all
those those children's story those fairy
tales I think that's quite wrong I think
that is a limited view in its own way
we're going to take two more calls and
take a short break
okay next is Mill Valley California yes
I'm a big fan of yours for at least 10
years and I own the DVD Basic Instinct
with your commentary on it which i think
is brilliant
thank you I consider myself a kind of
serve DVD commentaries yeah by the way
the best way to watch DVD commentaries
is with the subtitles on much more
complex but I have a question do you
have any plans to do more also in Basic
Instinct I've watched Sharon Stone many
times I think her performance actually
harks back to Kim Novak in Bell book and
candle and one comment on that well
can't you ever mention on my favorite
films I adored Kim Novak in Bell book
and candle the whole mistress you look
at a witch Neil calls and so on
oh that kind it's a little in that
quality that Kim Novak also has in
vertigo which I think even Hitchcock the
director didn't appreciate yes I think
actually Sharon Stone's picking up all
the great blonde hell Sharon Stone's
performance she's been she's been on the
scene for like 18 years or something
before she means basic in sing and she
worked her way up to that role and you
can feel you can feel in it actually
deep trick you know you can feel in it
Lana Turner
definitely definitely Kim Novick and I
think a little Madonna Sharon Stone does
Madonna better than Madonna has ever
been able to herself on the screen in
terms of doing other yes I would love to
do other documentary or other you know
other commentaries on DVDs of classic
films like that and I also have done you
know cameos like on cameos satirizing
myself in various films like it's passed
I'm in the Cameo hell Hartley is Henry
fool
Cheryl done yeas film a watermelon woman
I just sort of pop up and satirize
myself you know in them I enjoy very
much doing TV work I've done programs
and you know in England as well I love
the whole production called sir
as a professor as a an analyst of media
I've been very fortunate the last 13
years people to get behind the scenes of
media and see actually how things work
behind the stage behind the screen
Deerfield Illinois hi
I do enjoy your work professor Paglia
yeah I just want to I have two comments
one was you made an earlier comment
about lock Hall Derrida and Foucault
that I was that you misspoke Derrida is
actually Jewish dim it was de math Paul
demand who was the Nazi sympathizer I
thought there were two cases
well not Dairy Dairy dollars is an
Algerian is from Algiers and he's Jewish
born Jewish and never was a Nazi
sympathizer the second thing it was Paul
DeMint the second thing I I do take
issue with some of your comments about
theory I'm I've been in graduate school
and I'm now a teacher one of the reasons
that theory gained strength in the
Academy I believe is that was a concern
for the Enlightenment and you know
people do not realize that these
theorists are really commentators
they're just trying to describe say
postmodern world a postmodern condition
but many of the people influenced by
post structuralism take the Canon
you know contours so Hobbes very
seriously and I wonder what you thought
about that was it I think I think you're
quite right earlier I did I actually
miss a quotation about Paul demand from
my own
junk bonds incorporated it's all demise
not to sympathize I apologize but there
was a scandal over Derrida not
remembering it too clearly now that
began around 1988 in 1989 okay in
addition to paul de mon and there was
something i do it was it was involving
Nazis something and I'm sorry I'm not
pulling it up right now off it's like 15
years now since they have modere gas
star was already sinking when I came on
the scene 1991 because of this with it
was a scandal in its own right
I apologize for missing earlier now in
regard to the other matter Lacan Derrida
and Foucault are important within French
culture in my view because they are
critiquing the the Cartesian and
rational heritage in France it you could
not in my view it was absolutely
illegitimate to export that to America
and particularly to be making many
American students read those texts in
English translation I mean especially
the ones that are very labyrinths being
already in like like all in in French
without the problems that the post
structural structures are complaining
about in France never were the case in
America we have never had ok this this
vampirish burden of a of a fine art or
canonical tradition in America for
heaven's sakes or a frontier culture we
have no fine arts tradition here ok
we've been trying to implant it ok
wait this is being this is the the the
culture the creative Hollywood we do not
we are not rational I said it in the
French language is extremely limited in
the number the number of permissible
words that go back to the plays of rock
scene and so on so these arguments have
conditions it was madness okay on the
part of American academics to bring
these over the person who started it was
Edward Saeed whom I do admire a man of
great learning a leftist a member of the
palliative Didion Liberation
Organization and but you know he when he
was first talking about Foucault already
saw the limitations in Foucault in his
first writings on him but he's other
academics we just went into it I mean
they're still academics so any academic
who says Foucault is so learning so
Foucault is not learn it anyone who
thinks Foucault is learning ok does not
know what
learning is they have not done their
history lessons what was there was a
problem in American literary criticism
the new criticism had gotten to two
formulas in to focus on the individual
texts apart from biography or historical
context right it was a reaction against
the bibliographical excesses of an
earlier generation so what was needed
was to supplement new criticism by
bringing in historical contacts at
history and psychology because a new
criticism was also employed I felt that
was part of that movement to supplement
to bring it in what what is with these
constructions did okay what's to abandon
the whole thing and in poetry they can't
read a poem okay they can't this this
style of theory works only unnerve and
does not work on poetry right so we have
a bunch of Philistines again and
provincials who are teaching at very
high cost humanities to our
undergraduates okay and there is a
desert landscape I keep on must keep on
repeating in the elite schools okay in
the humanities really it's not going to
be cured it's going to another
generation okay before it before the
before we root out all this this theory
that was such a dead end when we come
back we're going to be able to ask you
some questions that our emailers have
asked about Noam Chomsky michael moore
jacqueline kennedy and also take up a
few of the your critics okay people like
molly ivins who have written the
sweeping generalization is Polly is
signature in fact her work consists of
damn little else and also will take up
Naomi Wolf what she said about you Polya
is the nipple pairs two persons Phyllis
Schlafly who poses as a sexual renegade
but is in fact the most dutiful of
patriarchal daughters and final we'll
also get a list from you people want to
know some books that you might recommend
the read we'll be back in just a few
minutes we'll have one hour left with
our guest Camille Talia I just think of
a full range of italian-american types
as it has never yet been portrayed there
really is a kind of kind of
condescension in the portrayal of
working-class types in general by that
by the film industry not in the 1930s
when people were closer to the
working-class roots but we have a kind
of a liberal bourgeoisie that runs the
runs the showbiz from
lay many of them now are refugees from
Ivy League schools which are which are I
guess who I would want to go there these
these arenas of a kind of desiccated
wasp system I think that is that is
quite quite pass I mean I think that
African Americans also have good reason
to complain about the by the swampthing
of American culture by by gangster
motifs from the streets I think that it
was very peril actually I think the kind
of crisis of representation that is
endured currently by African Americans
and with the gangsta style of hip-hop
and Italian Americans I think I think
perhaps alliance or bridge could be made
with with groups in in the
african-american community who are also
concerned about the portrayal of
American one of the best expressions of
the sort of equity feminism that I
believe in was given by Clare Boothe
Luce this event as we know is sponsored
by the Clare Boothe Luce Institute this
booth was fair minded clear-headed
utterly candid also elegant and gorgeous
but of course that's not important but
you can see for yourself now here's how
she summed up the mission of feminism
and I quote at length because it's
really one of my favorite quotes of all
time it is time to leave the question of
the role of women in society up to
mother nature a difficult lady to fool
you have only to give women the same
opportunities as men and you will soon
find out what it is not in their nature
what is in their nature and what is not
what is in woman's nature to do they
will do and you won't be able to stop
them but you will also find and so will
they that what is not in their nature
even if they are given every opportunity
they will not do and you won't be able
to make them do it now I love that brief
eloquent statement and I put it in an
article some time ago and the dissident
feminist and brilliant scholar and
social critic Camille Talia saw this
passage and she wrote me that she found
it quote
inspiring it sums up the first trust in
my adult career and I was so happy about
that because it's not easy to impress
Camille Polly is very easy to be
impressed been dazzled by her we're back
live with Camille Talia dr. Camille
Paglia thank you for joining us for
in-depth this month and we're going to
get right back to the to some of the
criticism and the questions and people
want to know first of all let's go to
Molly Ivins for criticism sweeping
generalization is your signature
in fact her work consists of damn little
oil well I think Molly Ivins had only
read things that I've written an op-ed
pages there are 800 pages long I mean
she clearly did not read any of my other
words like sexual persona 700 pages long
which is an enormous detail about about
you know evolved great artworks and
literary works I'm very sorry and I
think I don't know Molly Ivins regrets
the viciousness with which she greeted
my arrive on the scene it's unfortunate
because I actually think the Texas
feminists have a great style I loved in
Richards I mean I think that that kind
of stop talking so straight from the hip
way of talking is like is a you know is
excellent I mean so you know I think
that not ivan said that like in the
early 90s now she likes she likes to
pretend that we all should only text
people people in power she never never
text civilians I think she said just
everything but but there was no call for
her defame me in the way she had when
was a good example of the because she's
part of the inner feminist circle in
this country and here is a strong
talking woman who should have liked
should have liked and appreciated
other's strong talking woman and just
completely missed it completely missed
the fact that she and I have more in
common than we have different Naomi Wolf
you are a nipple pierced person's
Phyllis Schlafly well I owe me woman I
had a very long war culture war in the
early 90s went on for years and at this
point she's married and there's a mother
and it has gone evolved in her thinking
about many things but I criticized her
severely in the early 90s because of her
book the beautiness I thought was an
atrocious mess okay that it's saying
that the beauty was something being
cooked up by men and the in the sort of
capitalism to
keep women's self-esteem low and I was
one of the first voices in sexual
persona in my in my lectures to talk
about the need for aesthetics and that
that in fact that one of these
distinction marks of the human race is a
love of beauty and in the end that the
creation of beautiful artifacts or the
emergence of the beautiful person it's a
sign of advancing civilization and that
Stinnett feminism had you know in terms
of rejecting beauty as a male conspiracy
had said itself against culture the
other thing was the enemy was blaming
anorexia on the media and I said I said
anorexia is coming from mostly from
these highly competitive pressure
cookers of the white upper middle-class
families that send their children to the
Ivy League and then she sees anorexia in
the in her fellow students at Yale or in
or when she was a Rhodes Scholar then
she should be looking at the essay if
the family culture that produced it
where's that coming from
I said it was not its beckoning from the
media I think that that's expense that
betters absurd the obesity the same
thing well I mean the problem is that
top of it with the meat the public the
media is part of our cultural
environment insofar as it projects
images of women that are unrealistic
I mean obvious in the fashion magazine
and so on obviously this look a cultural
in a problem that we need to address the
anorexic per se I was denying was it was
caused by the media what the worst thing
is and Naomi was one the first to
comment on this in public too she would
be the lengthening okay the axial today
we say through Photoshop technique the
elongations of images okay of actual
living women including known celebrities
okay in magazines so that there is no
way that any human person not only could
be that thin but actually have legs that
long as the ones who customarily see I
do feel that the current media
environment in advertising and so on is
toxic for young people but but I don't
want to change the media I'm a libguide
elite in free speech the media is
protected by free speech the feminist
most days they want to wade into the
media and censor censor censor okay I
don't believe in that I believe in
education in uh supplying images from a
high art okay I want young people to see
in grade school the great variety of
female forms that have been glamorized
through history in
most cultures valorize the opulence
woman okay the heavy woman has always
been seen it's far more desirable than
the sticks and women our urban
industrial age so the answer is not to
censor the media and to carry on against
the media the answer is to reform
education now the anomaly law has
apparently never affected thanks to her
Ivy League education had never seen
apparently basically the richness we
have the actual our historical tradition
and I know that that so the solute is
another example but it would a Harvard
education I and I thought what these are
products of the Ivy League I felt when I
was trying to discuss with these women
how limited their actual background was
I thought why had paid up and given
truly humanistic so it's when I when I
go to England and talk to two
undergraduates at Oxford Cambridge women
undergraduate it's unbelievable the
difference compared to our Ivy League
students
these women are sophisticated they know
how to talk they have they have a
natural respect okay for for the Arts
and now we have all these is sort of a
tunnel vision kind of in a feminist so
they will come out who see the entire
world in black and white ideology of
black and white men bad women good okay
you know men oppressors and women
victims and everywhere not only is still
kind of doing that but we're no longer
in any kind of a war about it was a
flying match we were having the 90s do
you not teach at an Ivy League school
because you can't or because you don't
want I own persona non-grata
and most of the of America now a cadenas
I'm invited to speak it would never by
the literature Department are very
rarely by literature farmers usually by
history department
it could be classics anthropology
something like that we could because so
much of my work isn't is in those those
areas its abroad now I could leave you
know I love salt in arts college
environment it's my natural place I was
a Bennington and I'm here this is it is
so stimulating to me in my work to have
these apprentice artists in my committed
apprentice in my classroom like this it
is a constant I thank God I don't have
to deal with all those prep school grads
in the Ivy League campus but if I want
to leave America I could be teaching at
all kinds of the electric and teaching
at all kinds of major universities
worldwide outside of America I am seen
as a writer I'm really seen as a writer
here they say OSHA's that personalities
on TV
three they sort of know everything about
me even I've written like thousands of
pages of you know all these decades of
work and so on so I don't want to leave
America I love America my family came to
America and I want I want to make
education better and I think I think the
corner has been turned in American a
khadeem and the all the big fancy names
and fear of theory over the last 20
years are all in decline they're all
falling down and people are turning back
look at Harold Bloom sudden resurgence
today people can dismiss you know what
oh no bloom doesn't speak for acting
well bloom obviously has a vibe now or
the mass audience or the reading on to
survive with bloom and they now see him
as you know possible an evangelist for
for hi are at a time when when the
National Endowment for the Arts suddenly
all those years and it's under good
stewardship now okay by National
Endowment certainly did everything is
power to trash the image of the Arts or
just a Lea native from from you know
from the mass audience I mean the arts
need help okay literature humanity need
help in this country education has
become all about sentiment okay young
people are twittering sentiment you have
to be tolerant be nice not don't say
anything bad to so-and-so you know
little Johnny was crying after you
called him before that a wuss okay and
it's all turning into that date what is
that big care center stuff no I believe
that art should be absolutely presented
from the start it's not arts for people
give them finger paints to do know I'm
talking about history our history where
everything is in chronology give them a
time frame when I do at a time timeline
on the boards the kids look at what
their mouth is hanging open they've
everything a timeline okay they have no
sense of anything that they actual
straight they don't on a diagram a
sentence okay all the structure of
Education I was given to my parents
immigrant generation and to me the
quality of public education that I had
in upstate New York in a circus New York
it's gone now okay it's gone and it's a
scandal that's so scandal so like City
your first step in this second segment
go ahead hi Camille I'm a big fan oh
thanks um one of the things that I've
noticed in your work as a person who's
written and sold a bit of comedy myself
is a highly evolved sense of humor how
do you balance a sense of
humor with the dry academic world thank
you for that question is something a
great question that's one reason why
many people didn't take me seriously for
a very long time I thought well how can
a deep person would be funny okay to
them
comedy you know doesn't go with it so
that's like in Susan Sontag for all
those years she would pose as a very
deeply serious person okay you can't see
key matches either Simone de Beauvoir
sounds like a big belly laugh no I mean
it should be obviously bida privately
but they would the image of the
intellectual they had evolved against
the austere hyper critical intellectual
I don't believe that I believe like they
like the Hindu gurus okay are actually
the the aging masters and sages are
actually very funny okay they're they're
funny they're prankish and then masters
are known to be prankish so I mean I
give me comedy is a symptom of a
balanced perspective on life and people
who are going around like gloomy gusses
okay you know what like that Sonntag
style intellectual these people are
suffering from something coming from
their childhood has nothing to do with
the property intellectual response to
life right now now I again I'm coming
from a working-class background you look
like working-class people actually have
much more of a involved sense of humor
they laugh much more heartily okay then
then middle-class people do there's a
loss of physical and mental energy I
think in that transition from the
working class the middle class I observe
this happen you know in my own of my own
family that is as we as we moved is you
know it's next generation moved into the
professions of teaching and law and so
on there's a kind of sobriety that kind
of a northern European sobriety that's
expected of you but I I'm very prankish
in person in fact you know in college I
was on probation for pranks for pranks
yeah yes no I said like 39 I made a list
39 pranks they put my information or
maybe I love to make like surreal
environments there was like so what I'd
love to terrorize the anyone in
authority like the like the other
committees the administrators of the
dormitories it's like well there's one
thing I did like I staged a murder scene
or the ones one of the doormen came back
to her room after a beer blast and I had
staged the thing with like a cough red
cough syrup for blood and I'm like my
envelope opener for the knife and
chair tipped over and do it on-screen
another time I took the clocks I found
that the clocks could come off the wall
in the dormitory is large clocks like
some of I went about on chair and I took
them down and I put them two of them
into into the twin beds of the
counselors in my dormitory so when they
came back from the beer blast I loved it
they came back and in the clock faces
where it tucked up with the sheets
around there on their face and dead they
came in this screen okay I'm calm and
then the thing that finally I think that
was able to put me on probation
I had shaving cream I was coming back
from going back to the shower and I just
put a big question mark and shaving
cream on the resident advisors door
which meant like question authority well
it removed the varnish from the door
okay so they cost to it that was it I
was on probation so but you know it was
just 60 votes when they get these you
know we're going to the stock exchange
and throwing dollar bills off the
balcony going sooie sooie I mean so it
was a part of that spirit of a sixties
what politician has the best sense of
humor today mm-hmm
oh my god who has a sense of humor at
all today I mean in America oh my god
I'll give you a chance to think about it
a little bit Charleston South Carolina
you're next
it's a little high yeah you're hot
you're cute I love you oh listen I have
a question I saw a statistic that was
staggering that 4% of the American
population that being black males
between 15 and 40 years old commits
about 60% of the crime in the United
States and and this and naturally this
follows that racial profiling policemen
who see these kind of statistics and
deal with it on a daily basis are prone
to look towards black males who create a
lot of crime after 9/11 I saw a lot of
people interviewed blacks particularly
who and I paid closer attention to this
and and they were asked since 9/11 do
you have a problem with someone of Arab
origins or looks being closely
scrutinized racially profiled and they
had no problem with it whatsoever and I
thought this was a large hypocrisy I
just wondered how you felt about racial
profiling and those
well I think it's inevitable you know
that police are in an inner-city
environment where there is a high
concentration on african-americans it
will seem like their racial profiling I
happen to witness very unseemly scenes
in the 1980s when I would be traveling
by car on the New Jersey Turnpike from
Philadelphia to New York and I saw that
the troopers or maybe they were just
local police had out of the car
constantly it seemed whole
african-american families who are
standing under very dangerous conditions
along the side of the road in a
situation that I saw really was not with
an American ok I if indeed the troopers
or local police felt there was reason to
search the car of these particular
African Americans I believe that the
cars should have been taken a to arrest
stop or to you know Opik they were
thinking me that it was a deliberate
effort to humiliate and to intimidate
other drivers and of course the reason
that was happening is that there was
such a drug run going on from from from
Florida all the way to New York City ok
so that's a big New Jersey Turnpike was
above the policy point of intervention
because they look like a kind of ally so
I think that the questions about racial
profiling
you know our legitimate ones I think
many you know many African Americans
drive driving a car it's ok you feel
that there is the subject of excessive
scrutiny I think they probably are right
like yes obviously it you know I think
where it's gone too far our situations
like you hear about like for example I
was hearing recently on the radio the
first reports about the shooting that
happened in City Hall where a councilman
was was murdered point-blank with a gun
and in the first moments it seemed as if
the shooter was free they thought that
he had escaped and was somewhere either
in the building or in the area and so
the alerts that went out over the radio
I was listening to to the New York radio
the alerts were never mentioned race now
because because of this is because of
that kind of a censorship
events I turns out that the shooter
actually was himself cut down by it by a
police under under completion hood on
the on the floor of the council chamber
but I think that you know
our ways that clearly where our
hypersensitivity to racial matters it
goes against logic and there are other
places where African Americans have very
legitimate grievances I think in the
public realm California moranga hi my
name is Kareem and I'm calling in
response to a comment I was made earlier
regarding security in America and how
voters are possibly going to lean
towards the bush because of these
policies and basically supporting the
military and actually from what what I'm
experiencing and talking to people and
so forth people don't feel secure with
Bush at all because he was in office
nine months you know and we had 9/11 and
personally if I have a security system
that fails me you know I put them it put
it in place
I would actually change that you know if
I if it fails me and something happens
to me I would change and and another
thing is after 9/11 we went in the
Taliban we still haven't found Osama bin
Laden and and basically Bush's being is
tap-dancing and I don't feel secure
personally about those the whole
security issue Thanks California let's
leave it at that we got your spouse
thank you I agree with everything that
the caller says yes in my view in my
view the billion dollars that is being
poured into Iraq every week should be
going to build up our own security
infrastructure in this country or we are
a local emergency response teams are
still inadequately trained and supplied
we have all kinds of security problems
around chemical plants and nuclear
plants in this country I think that just
just I could go on for five hours I'm
afraid on the Iraq issue but there is a
tremendous waste of national assets
seems to me on this adventure and it
with no end in sight Cranston Rhode
Island
yeah I happen to disagree with you the
Carlyle Group which is friends with
George Bush has risen from the number
fifth military supply to the number one
ISIL there yes taking into consideration
globalized fascism when you when you put
the bomb Wayne went on when a few who
want to impose total control arm on the
many then then power has been
centralized if you take into
consideration Homeland Security or the
Patriot Act or arm no support for a free
internet based college education or the
Bush's role in the 9/11 attacks uh
taking into consideration the CIA
reports that that the Bush family were
friends with the Osama bin Laden's
family and and that the CIA knew about
these attacks prior to the attack on
9/11 some of this information is
available at info wars.com thanks
Cranston well I mean we can't just blame
the Bush administration I was vocal in
the 1990s about the differences seems of
the Clinton administration to the first
attack on the World Trade Center 1993 I
mean I thought that people in the media
had dropped it all so I think the media
bears an enormous responsibility for a
lot of these problems in there again all
absorption in domestication issues there
in celerity and the media also deserves
tremendous blame for for the sliminess
in the face of our build-up toward war
last year we never had a real national
debate on the the invasion of Iraq and
then they and then they also blame the
Democratic senators of my own party
Democrats in has laid down flat like
like Persian rugs and let everyone walk
around whether we had no national debate
on this question of war and I think that
the population would seem to like by
polling support the the invasion of Iraq
was in fact misinformed about about the
potential consequences of this and what
a mammy that whole region okay anyone
who reads anything about the history of
that region going all the way back to
antiquity has to fear this naive
Eve stepping into this problem from
which I don't see any date of
expectation in sight we have just 40
minutes left our emailers have been wild
about asking you about different people
okay if you could could I would like to
run through some of the people they want
to get your opinion on and it will go on
Condoleezza Rice I think she's a great
mind I really admired her for a long
time I think she's a little askew Lee
and calm okay I'm a little unnerved by
someone with an F such an evident lack
of personal relationships sending gut
you know families you know it represents
a family families to fight and die in
Iraq and I'm afraid
in recent weeks with it's apparent where
she was kind of not willing take
responsibility for problems again from
her own office that her star may be
besmirched by I used to again because
I'm so interested in the idea of a woman
president we asked annalisa reckless in
recent years when she I love the way she
takes States the way she she's a but she
comes out for a press conference she
she's able to like to handle the mic
handle the media this is what we need
okay our first woman president should be
studying Condoleezza Rice's you know
manner plus she's a very cultivated
woman who is a master of the piano as
well as an athletic woman so I think
she's a role model and someone in so
many ways Noam Chomsky well Noam Chomsky
you know I had said some nasty things
about me so I'm going to try to take a
high road okay about him I think that
his linguistics theories are overblown
okay I think that he is a that his uh
his theories have been a kind of fascism
in a khadeem I don't think that he is a
deeply learned person in the history of
world languages I think that he is
someone who is has a very distorted way
of proceeding a reality and he is one of
the great anti-american voices who has
been comfortably ensconced with his job
that he doesn't even apply for at MIT
all those years he's even done in his
field okay Foreign Relations I think
he's a kind of I think he hallucinates a
bit about foreign policy on the other
hand let me just say this okay
the Bush administration by going into
Iraq
managed to vindicate okay no chance of
entire view okay so it's just one thing
one of the main concerns I have of
what's happened in Washington is that
Noam Chomsky's views which seemed
absolutely delusional now seem to have
the ring of truth to them Matt Drudge
Matt Drudge is one of the one of the
great independent voices of our time I
like him he that the Drudge Report is
the first thing I turn to when I go
online it's the last thing I turned to
before I go offline if I'm not a long
time I'm on it for four other times okay
he this this is this is the net he is
the web okay it he has put his in even
though he's only putting links up there
okay what is his choice of like he's
like he's like an improvisational artist
to me it's like in the main line of Andy
Warhol it was a great to me in real
world normal for me to his the most
poetic way in freeform way that he
treats his site okay is to me one of the
unique experiences of our time I really
respect him I we don't agree on politics
I mean he's like what you're
conservative in his thinking than me but
but I I think he is satisfy when the
arts the fine arts are actually not
producing anything particularly
interesting become you know sometimes
rather bizarre with particular these
exhibitions that come from England where
you have you know by second cows you
know of bodies on display and so on May
I think Drudge is actually one of our
best examples of a performance artist
and his standards on radio he's a master
of radio completely different amendment
has been his website Phoenix Arizona see
you next to you there go ahead Phoenix
yes go ahead sir you're on there okay
sorry I wanted to ask miss taglio a big
and a tiny flower question my main
question is in studying popular culture
in relation to the Western canon how do
you expect students of your work or
whose Evers how does that benefit their
understanding of the Canon as and also
because I actually think your work
actually kind of sort of mythologize as
the present my second major might
question is just do you have any
recommendations on writers I really
admire dear Noah on the rina rina I'm
gay myself and I really a deeply admired
you so many things had to be said there
that you said and anyone that is you
recommend that that you find insightful
and regard to homosexual contemporary
and otherwise okay all right oh wait no
yes totally
overall theory holding together my work
is this say that the judeo-christianity
never did defeat paganism as history
books say but rather that Greco Roman
paganism was underground
during the medieval period and erupted
at three key moments one was the
Renaissance most people would accept
that that that was a revival of
greco-roman humanism and artistic motifs
and so on the second eruption of
paganism was romanticism where you had
all this primeval stuff which I call the
colognian coming up from him from the
earth a demonic field calls and all
those things then the third grade
eruption of paganism is the age of
Hollywood which is what I call the 20th
century so that what we're getting in
the pagan the pantheon of the great
other great studio era where you had
that deification of the stars magma and
that's that's incredible
kind of a manufacturer of stars of level
of a Dietrich or Harlow and so on Rita
Hayworth etc so yes III feel that modern
popular culture is the final term okay
in this in this long story
therefore the wasteland a view of things
TS Eliot's away--so 1922 saying that
Western culture is in fragments and
pieces collapsed I said that that is
complete delusion okay yes maybe the
fine arts tradition was collapsing into
cubism I'm a great admirer of Picasso so
I don't mean to diminish cubism but that
whole kind of view a pessimistic view of
a culture being at an end of the West
being over okay which we see even in
Samuel Beckett's Waiting for Godot
following World War two which in so
influenced Foucault and which is a play
this is a Sonntag idolizes on a play
that I absolutely abhor from the moment
I saw it in college I said this is bleak
view of culture of life as nothing but
an empty line
a but one poor tree trying to come back
to life in a bunch of hobos they're
chewing on chicken bones and no woman in
sight by the way one of the great
misogynist plays of all time and that is
not a view of culture instead what was
going on in Hollywood at that moment
again fantastic entertainment Hollywood
supplied what modern avant-garde culture
has denied was possible any longer
emotion and beauty and and in the body
okay so that's why the mass audience
gravitated toward popular culture that's
why when you get people like not only
woven out in others and others other
feminists okay where I was bad-mouthing
or soluti sizzling bad-mouthing the mass
media I say you know wait get off these
four and three theories you know which
are they're all coming from the
Frankfurt School commodification all
that stuff okay get off that and realize
the degree to which the working class in
the mass audience not only here but now
worldwide okay has fed off these
magnificent Mexican immigrant images so
I do see a continuity I see continuity
in the West going all the way down from
our from the founding great works of
literature NAR into the great classic
movies and so on okay there's a lot of
trash in popular culture right now which
any audience only don't mean that young
people should be absorbing a diet of
trash now what you'll just take second
we're going to get to that list tl a
list but we're going to get a lot of
people you're going to recommend people
read it we'll put that all together a
few minutes sure government limited
support of the Arts all right Gavin our
government support of the Arts should be
a given it should be a given in any of
the miniscule amount that is given by
the governor but who is to blame they
for this declining amount ok the arts
community itself thanks by identifying
if it's cutting edge your work with it
was artworks that profane established
religious values why should any taxpayer
feel ok that he is he or she is
underwriting
something like Andre Serrano's piss
Christ where you had a crucifix
submerged in a beaker of the artists
urine now is a lot to be said for
avantgarde transgressive are I could I
could give a whole lawyers been
Mapplethorpe a man I love maple syrup I
love maple Foreman but the idea that the
government needed to support
Mapplethorpe at that
day when he was already rich to pay from
his own works he was not a struggling
artist at the time of that so I wrote an
essay actually for tikkun magazine
that's a collected insects dog American
culture where I said I adore Mabel so I
was like I wrote an homage to his great
portrait of Patti Smith from the cover
of horses for civilization magazine I
love maple farming and I'd lost
everything transgressive about him
nevertheless that's not the whole
history of art not all art has been
transgressive the whole oppositional
view of Arc is simply a heritage of
romanticism for the late 18th century
early 19th century most of our for human
history has a celebratory of power it
has always been that the church you know
gave money for its first celebration of
its values the government or princes the
medicube princes David making money for
celebration themselves the pyramids or
most local history of art has an
undercurrent propaganda underwriting by
the powerful in the rich is true
nevertheless the workmen the artisans
produced fantastic objects that are part
of the cultural heritage of everyone in
the world I come from an Italian culture
today where it's assumed by the peasant
in the field might be talking that the
one whom I came that the operas are
their heritage that Michelangelo Sistine
Chapel ceiling is their heritage there's
no sense it belongs to any elite all
that stuff net so what's happened in
this country is this the way the the
arts community itself managed to shoot
itself in the foot okay like that that
wouldn't when they brought the Saatchi
collection over to the Brooklyn Museum
of Art and in this nothing of any
religious consequence or or or reference
in the whole exhibition so for one thing
and that is this Madonna figure but by a
Nigerian British artist named Chris
Ofili where you had the elephant dung
being used for her breasts and and
little cutouts of women women's
genitalia from pornographic magazines
they paced it all around her that's the
part that you know the Liberals are in
defending this often leave out now I
could give a lecture on that explaining
what he meant by that in terms of
African traditional African fertility
religion and so on and there are many
potential meanings there now there is a
bit of museum what a bunch of coconuts I
mean they didn't they didn't they knew
owes in half and they wanted sensations
they want to offend Catholic Catholic
sensibilities okay sailor to lux the
Catholic Church is like you can you can
say anything in the Catholic Church okay
yes but
but you about anything about Judaism or
or Islam for many years was completely
organ impossible okay so so the Brooklyn
Museum should have realized it was going
to be this and supported in some way by
possibly having a whole of maybe a book
either brochure or something before you
enter the exhibition about the history
of transgressive are the history of
objects that offend so if they
established a star something to give the
whole thing context right and then we
would have had the explosion that you
did there were two Giuliani waded into
it okay with you know Isis bite bite
bite by trying to cut off and support to
the Brooklyn Museum so I'm saying is the
reason that that we have this
pathetically small budget for the net
for than that for the Arts in this
country okay is because of the arrogance
with which the arts community has
conducted itself by saying saying to the
mainstream audience in America we're
about spitting on you taking your money
and spitting on you now what kind of art
what kind of art teaching what kind of
art education can go forward with it
with that kind of attitude Ocala Flordia
a higher doctor I was listening to your
words and you mentioned intellectual a
few times now I am just I come from a
blue-collar background just a high
school graduate now I'm a very
successful businessman I looked up
intellectual in the dictionary and it
says two rationale as opposed to
emotional and my question is a
hypothetical now might does not make
right but throughout history it seems
that men have run the world due to their
physical aggressiveness as opposed to
the submissiveness of women now when it
comes to feminism does it hold true that
that feminism would not exist except for
the benevolence and the tolerance of men
and feminism is actually one collective
one collective aggressive stroke away
from extinction well I think feminism is
permanent it goes through phases I mean
there are times when it's a surge and
then Dominion then a subside again but
actually feminism is a part of the
West's legacy and when so many people on
campus and PC campuses you know
bad-mouthed Western culture for heaven
sakes feminism and indeed the entire
concept of civil liberties is a product
of Western individualism goes all the
way back to the ancient Greeks now
feminism itself we can no trace so there
there are there are feminist expressions
of the various point by isolated women
from the medieval period on probably
about what but it really has its roots
just following the period of revolutions
in the late 18th century that after the
French Revolution and the American
Revolution and you began see women like
you know Mary Shelley who is the
daughter of a prominent of feminists who
are who want to achieve the same level
of men but yes insofar as it's the
modern capitalist Industrial Revolution
you produced a system that allows women
to escape from the drudgery of housework
and to be freed from dependence on
either a husband or a father okay for
doing justice in themselves in some way
yes feminism is a product of male
achievements and is there have been
there always been two strands and
feminism there is a kind of puritanical
strand and it was often covered up is
that many of the founders of feminism
and the women's suffrage movement of the
19th century were ardent prohibitionists
okay wanted to stop the public sale of
liquor because they felt that liquor was
something that caused problems at home
that men drank off you know drink drink
up the family income on gin and then
abuse they beat there we were oh you
know wives and the band and their
children son and so forth and so their
instant and then there's a kind of pro
sex or libertarian or
the kind of sort of extreme and
extravagance theatrical strand in
feminism that I kind of belong to that
goes back to Victoria what will and so
there's been an argument even within
feminism and now and then one one part
of the movement has kind of dominance
and then the other one comes back so I
was part of the pro-sex part of it in
1960s and all of a sudden is the doors
were shot in my face okay the first
proved many reasons I love the Rolling
Stones I was told the Rolling Stones are
sexist like I thought that hormones play
a part a sexual identity oh I was told
that this was all nonsense editor so it
was
proce x-wing of feminism lost ground
throughout the 70s and 80s and but we
made this enormous resurgence again in
the 90s and I think that it's a probe
man a respectful of men if man men and
ever special relationships like I think
I think it's some kind of stride in
feminism that you're thinking about of
the 80s of the early 90s I think it's
you know that's that's pretty much gone
Redmond Washington hello
I am a mother who's homeschooling my son
and I'm very interested in a curriculum
that would help him understand the Arts
in the world I'm so do you have any
suggestions thank you and I can I just
pick on to that email or who wants to
know what do you how do you deal with
how do you treat a kidney gardener in
order to make them a free thinker oh I
suppose didn't well in terms you'll have
to face this is art is etre in terms of
of e of the arts I mean I think it's so
important to expose the child to images
from from there are some huge look
one-volume
history of art books that are often used
in freshman college years that are like
the famous one by Janssen from history
government my parents had a book by John
Brooke that was like there was the story
of art that began with the earliest you
know cave art things and when it moved
all who all through the period I think
it's never too early to introduce the
child to images now one of the problems
is that many images from history the
Western tradition are nude so I so then
so I think that each family has to make
a decision to the degree to which you
think that children should be looking at
nudes or not I believe that your
children in Europe your European kids
are you seeing nudity everywhere and
that it hasn't caused you know personal
corruption I think that it were possible
you child should be taken to a museum my
parents I took me from upstate New York
to visit the Metropolitan Museum of Art
in New York City and these were it was
mind-boggling experience on me I must
have seen the museum when I was three or
four years old
mind-boggling just to see the magnitude
of the of the great the great stone
Sphinx is of queen hatshepsut that are
there and considers magnificent
paintings and unfortunately smaller
galleries and smaller smaller towns
to be more contemporary art I think it
encourage the child to study the image
because today with movies and TV
everything is moving moving moving too
rapidly okay but they are of examining a
complex work and really looking at it
there and so many of the great classic
works of the medieval period and the
Renaissance are in the Baroque are on
religious topics so I think that even
very conservative families who feel who
feel that they don't want nudity in the
images they show they can certainly help
discuss with the child some of the great
masterpieces of with the biblical
stories from the Sistine Chapel ceiling
and so on I think that you need to go to
the library only did buy books I mean
all these things are available in the
library I think that what if a child has
to have your encouragement and I
certainly was encouraged the tree are
seriously by my family couple quickly
and a couple more people from the emails
Jackie Kennedy well I wrote actually a
piece on Jackie Kennedy I thought what a
classy woman she was I thought she had
such elegance and refinement I really
you know it mired her I'd let go but she
held herself which is which is a part of
the heritage of being trained to your
writing horse respect marathon picture
this wonderful quality and I think part
of the great tragedy is the more we
learn about what was really going on the
way she was personally undermined by the
the extent of the you know view
philandering by her husband I think that
even even the legacy of his
administration is starting to suffer
from that I feel bad about it because I
think that the Kennedys both of them a
fire in an appetite for political
participation in my generation I will
never forget the ecstasy I felt when the
John Kennedy in 1968 after after there's
some knowlins of the Eisenhower years
the image of woman that made me I mean
Mamie Eisenhower was a very nice lady
but she was no Jackie Kennedy they had
this like style and vitality in the sort
of forward-thinking and articulate in
this old John Kennedy he's articulate as
innocent in the press conference they
were a wonderful combination Michael
Moore well okay I agree with him about
politics probably about many things okay
but I I must deplore and condemn the
take the methods he's using to
fictionalize productions that he is
claiming
our documentaries okay so insofar as he
was guilty of restaging a scene
involving a rifle at a bank in part of
his Lobby I mean I think that there's no
room for that is no room for dishonesty
at the New York Times or in in Hollywood
and so I wish that Michael Moore would
stop using tactics of defamation and
deceit as part of his political agenda
dr. Laura Schlessinger well dr. laura is
um you know is a tell me what if I so
she taught me if I haven't you in the
car I get on the radio I always enjoy
listening to her she's tough she's a
tough cookie but I think there's
something over the years maybe a little
bit too brittle about her presentation I
mean she basically thinks that you all
can just pull yourself up by your
bootstraps out of life and it is the way
to do it I think that there's not enough
room there's enough relaxation there's
not enough room for comedy shall we say
in her presentation next is Toledo hello
Toledo hello admire dr. paglia and I've
seen her many times by the way I a was I
graduated from Berkeley in the late
sixties Oh and became very liberal of
course and had a great education there
and then I got my first job and got a
paycheck and found out how much taxes I
was paying and that changed my mind a
bit but on education I must tell you I
just met a young lady accidentally in a
restaurant the other day and she
graduated high school with an A average
and we just talked while we're waiting
for our tables and she said have you
traveled a lot nice I guess and she said
where you been and I said well most
recently England and she said what
language do they speak there oh now this
is really a commentary on what the
doctor has said several times during the
day what do you feel about school
vouchers
and secondly I think by the way on
another matter you personify sexiness oh
oh thank you [ __ ] so you know my
declining years okay yes vultures why
support the vouchers I support anything
which can can throw a bomb into the
calcified public education system can
release it from its terrible enslavement
it has by the teachers unions at the
present moment I think it's been a
charge I just a tragic decline when it's
every kind of idiocy anyway I think if
there was remember there were legal
attempts to stop even experiments of
having high schools in the inner city
for there were all males okay because it
was thought that if you could just say
and I agree with that we have the kids
to trouble kids all kinds of experiments
that could be done if we just free up
the the you know the education system
from the the social engineers among us
but yeah there are problems you're very
parochial interlocutor there at the
restaurant yes it's a terrible problem
America is an enormous country that is
the size of you know it's like of
several Europe's I mean we have we have
we have four states okay that are larger
than Europe itself and and Europe is
like such a patchwork of languages and
cultures and there's and also can
international connections around the
world a connection between India and you
know in Britain is this is intense so in
America we're very insular despite the
enormity of the country and efforts has
to be made by educators to open up the
minds of the students to the great world
that's out there but not in this kind of
a multi-culti way that says all all the
peoples of the world of this great
peaceful nation and the only evil people
in the world are the Americans there
would be a wonderful paradise on earth
it wasn't for evil America that's the
way they taught that taught all this
etcetera right I think that that most of
public education and including college
these days is a waste of time a
tremendous waste of time kids are madly
bored I think there should be much more
development a return to trade schools
where kids are learning something I
think that every single course is being
taught has to be evaluate in terms of
what the kids are getting I think the
kids need help with learning how to
- how to house keep the old Home
Economics thing with odd hopelessly you
know uh you know outmoded and that kind
of thing people need how to you know how
to balance a checkbook keeps on learning
things at home I think minorities need
help with business and how to how to
manage small business businesses to give
them you know a leg up whereas people
from the upper-middle class you don't
have so you can learn things about
investments in the stock market from
their family people from the work
mudstone the other emptiness of so much
public education these days they the
different volley of it the mediocrity of
it in America is it's shocking to the
mind I'm I'm in favor of of kids not
going directly into college but actually
if their family support is sending them
abroad take that money and send them
abroad have them return to college later
have more adults returning to college we
need much more interplay of Ages okay I
think that the social pressures in high
school are terrible right now they're
just did just take to keep on graduating
kids and it's like big group of eight
the age group often like that and of
course you can't keep them back all
haven't forbid they can't read or write
don't keep them back with their social
promotion or don't they'll suffer
psychologically you know they can't read
and write graduate them without reading
or writing skills etcetera etcetera I
think we need much more a mixing of ages
in in schools and I think that we have
to free people from the tyranny of
school I think young the reasons one
reason I thought for the Columbine
massacre okay was that your boys pinned
in school pins okay their physical
energies need to do something they find
something for them to do and then Oh
then we incentivize the kids okay they
can't buy liquor oh no okay so because
they can't buy alcohol to the 21 they're
all taken every kind of weird drug race
that is like I mean there's some from to
Special K analyzed like ecstasy there
pickling their brains I mean we have a
whole pickled brain generation moving
forward alcohol is you know you
violently sick if you overdo it
evaporates it all got from the system by
the next day we're producing
unsophisticated okay you know your kids
with minds of jello who are uneducated
and we can't find England obviously on
the map if people couldn't find you rack
on the map also okay that's what really
got me about last year okay but we were
being real being forced into a war right
what
Americans wouldn't have that remotest
idea where it where Iraq was or any
sense of mid-eastern the history of in
eastern politics or the idea that the
British Empire had made this mistake
before getting into Iraq and following
BC they cutting up of the Ottoman Empire
after World War one st. Louis Oregon all
right hi doctor and speaking of pickle
brains uh engineer opinion on this that
thinking of Pat Schroeder and her what
she accomplished with others in the
Congress military I certainly opposed
women in military when it comes to
combat positions and things that
certainly women in the military have a
very big place and it should get bigger
but I have a huge problem with that if I
could say one of the thing about if I
remember Gulf War one there were a lot
of women I guess in reserve units that
went and afterwards the military didn't
want this out but there was a huge
number that became pregnant while they
were there were others that after six
months were had to go home for one
reason for but because of maternal
reasons I have a hard problem with women
even at the service academies because it
does come down to a combat type
situation I've been stood in her
opinions and on the subject yeah when I
gave a lecture at West Point I got an
earful about that from a member of the
cadets I think it is injurious allow
about women income it wouldn't have not
actually ever served in combat even even
as I understand it and it is really our
army they're not really on the front
lines
the thing is in our modern military of
course when you have such advanced
technological machinery if you have
women jet pilots and certainly seems to
me serve extremely as well as men
probably if they if they're if they are
able to pass the test without any
lowering of the standards therefore for
women as we've done in you know in cases
of admission women to fire in some fire
companies local fire companies but yeah
I think honestly it's still not known to
what extent do would would witness
presence in a combat unit or compromised
cohesion I'm willing to have an open
mind about it I'm perfectly willing as a
feminist to say all right this is one
area where we're preps it's not working
at women but unfortunately this argument
also crosses over to gays in the
military and they're the idea that the
game should be drummed out of the
military because they their presence to
would break down cohesion and situations
where you have the soldiers literally
sleeping on top of each other and in
other conditions where you might have
the temperature 20 below or something
like that you know all these questions
are they're very thorny ones we haven't
been in a war to test it for very long I
certainly agree that the military should
not be a laboratory for social
engineering and I think that is what
happened in the 1990s where people were
trying to enforce social pathology of
course but your culture changes ahead
when in fact the military is our
fighting armor we're going to depend
depend that I I post any kind of misuse
of the military for any reasons as now
in Iraq where we are are brilliantly
training military is being used for
police duties for which it is
ill-equipped and our soldiers are not
just being killed Hey the figures are of
core the media as usual is suppressing
those sitting kills Isis are being
wounded ok there with light us in their
wits like the loss of limbs ok people
are not going to walk with the rest of
the lives and so on all of that is being
kept from us right now so I you know
chef man with a comment yes hello go
ahead
hi there's a first time ever heard about
you I'm sorry but I also get some of
your books in the future you're very
interesting Googlers and pleasantly I
like to know two things what do you
think of the Democratic Party again not
you know taking the black food for
granted and just going on about their
business and you know they don't have
the White House and they don't have any
get Congress if it's going to happen to
them again if they ignore the black vote
and also what do you think about liberal
arts in America you know the black
African Americans have been protesting
I've been saying with loud voices to
include African American Studies into
the liberal arts programs and so forth
and so on
and of course
that sector would not allow it at least
not at the level of what African
Americans want thanks Pennsylvania well
number one it is interesting I think
that the only enjoyable person to watch
right now is Al Sharpton okay who is
this because the only person who dares
to be sticking out and all the other
Democratic candidates are very
constrained by their focus groups and
they're in their advisors or the only
thing like they're walking mummies they
can't they can't actually be totally
honest about their real views on any
issue so I will see what's going to
happen I think it would be a very big
wake-up calls with Democratic Party if
there's a split in you know Al Sharpton
takes his votes and and moves with them
it's voted for Jesse Jackson actually
the 1988 presidential primary just
because I wanted to get a you know I
want more more candidates of color and
more women at the top level and so we're
just not getting them I think it says
it's something really wrong in terms of
the I mean there there are many seems to
me asked American candidates at the at
the level at the local level at the
level of state governance or even in the
Congress and they really we need to
bring them forward more now in terms of
this is one of the things that happen
actually in the Academy in the last 25
years the first the African American
Studies departments and then and then
the know because Latin American Studies
departments and so on that this is a
process of kind of splintering that
occurred in the humanities that I don't
think was in the best interest of the
humanities overall certainly it got
African American issues much more into
the curriculum in college and and also
at the high school level I was happy to
hear that the Harvard Department of
African American Studies is now going to
move more to the African directions
start to stress the African side the
question of African history African
language like that's what I felt what is
to read it is much much much more
necessary but I unfortunately I I don't
like that any kind of fragmentation in
the humanities I don't want a situation
where you say well black teenagers
should only be taught african-american
culture I think that's terrible I think
that black teenagers to not just read
african-american literature and they
should be exposed to whole of the
history of the Arts
Seattle yes hi dr. regalia hi let me say
it's a start that I'd like you and
you've got to be the most interesting
woman I've ever seen on TV thanks a lot
and I've seen you at other occasions us
Oh
are you there called lost the caller
call are you there
cool I'm sorry we love it here that's
too bad I apologize let me go through
your books sure what will people find in
sexual persona sexual persona is a view
of the whole history of Western culture
that begins with cave art moved into
ancient Egypt and Greece and down to
Italian art and so on and then it goes
into into literature tried to show what
are the fundamental themes in in Western
loose or non I wrote it in a way that
should be accessible to the general
reader so people a sense of history
dance entranced and concern for the
collection of my essays I'm a huge
variety of topping that's my second half
a collection actually it contains know
that the biggest thing no law in the
arena is my social and political
philosophy and then it has a wide
variety because I'm the Clintons and
then all kinds of other things that my
my the program I did in England about
the about the penis penis is an art as
well as a transcripts of videos I did
like with the drag queen glenda orgasm
okay ah who's the real name is Glenn
Bell very Oh in New York so documentary
I did and all kinds of things are in
there sex art in American culture
I can use my urban from an initial
articles on Madonna on date rape it has
the big sa junk bonds and corporate
raiders which is which is mice a long
attack on contemporary of campuses and
the birds the birds okay is a book the
British Film Institute asked me to
contribute to the series and it's this
book experiments on their most popular
it is a scene-by-scene analysis of this
great masterpiece by Alfred Hitchcock it
is for it's written for the general
reader it's meant it when you start that
it's every possible interesting little
detail about the movie about the sets
the costumes and so on but as you read
it it the movie should unfurl in front
of your eyes it starts in the beginning
and so it's a great book force to train
that you'll feel you have seen the
entire bill from beginning to end but
moving in front of you Mariama torgo's
Nick do you know her she was someone who
once had a reputation at Duke University
and is now at the margins of well Emily
this is what she wrote about you yet I
suspect that Thalia is going to be true
to her past in ways she does not even
suspect that she's going to end up
disappointing and alienating everyone
including her current backers that she's
going to self-destruct
paulien may surprise me she's done it
before but I'm afraid she'll keep
talking when she has nothing more to say
well here it is ten years later so there
are so many people in the early 90s that
oh she's going to have a chicken or 15
minutes of fame what's that 13 years
later and I'm still here yeah a lot of
those ladies who are like rug big wheels
and Akademi when I came out who they
were met I came on the scene like like
an explosion I thought well who is she
now who is she a patient who was like
totally unpublished if he was who had
been struggling for most of my career
and I wrote a 700 page book which by the
way that woman has never read okay and
Molly Ivins never read and not only will
he never read okay so all these people
who think they know so much about me
they've never read the master work which
is sexual for Sony they know nothing
well we know more about you than we did
three hours ago thank you for your time
thank you realization Camille Polly our
guest on in-depth for this month thanks
for joining us